you
see ken's on the horn now
this is my pen
is this your pin
did you leave this over here
maybe i maybe i don't know okay
okay we're i think we're all set now
okay i think we're ready to go um i i
appreciate everybody taking
the you know battling this little storm
we have out here it's not a huge one yet
that i see
um
up north where i came from way up uh up
on the littleton area it was
not much tall up there and it got worse
as she went south here
so uh here we are today we have hearings
on three bills
and just some of the ground rules and
and reminders for folks one can our
representative weiler we have a little
rule in here when the phone goes off you
buy lunch for everybody
[Laughter]
so what we have today is we have the
three bills and the the first bill on
the daca is going to be 11 31 and as a
reminder from folks that we know you've
you've come some very long distance to
get here and others have driven through
this snow which is not comfortable but
if you
have something that's written we'd
appreciate that being provided to the
committee so the clerk doesn't have to
go and take all these notes they can
reference your testimony
and that will say see attachment in the
record so that will become part of the
record also if there's items which are
being discussed
when we get really repetitive that's how
we end up with these hearings going two
three four five hours and we're hearing
the same thing over and over so try to
you know if you uh endorse something
that has previously been said stay that
and rather than having to go through it
all over again
that really helps us all and it helps
you to get out of here i know you don't
want to spend your whole day here either
so we are streamed this this is live
it's uh anywhere that you you know have
a computer you can stream and listen to
what's going on today
uh you you when you testify we have a
mic right available there and you push
the button
that means you're live and you're we're
ready to go ahead
so i'd like to again welcome everybody
to the committee we have a good number
of committee members here today and i
appreciate that and i thank them so i'd
like to open up the hearing on 1131.
this is a bill relative to facial
covering policies for schools
and with that i'd like to
recognize our representative whose prime
sponsor of the bill
representative weiler welcome ken to our
meeting
thank you mr chairman members of the
committee representative ken weiler
rockingham district 13 the towns of
hampstead and kingston
what just happened since we filed this
bill last september
mass requirements are being canceled
everywhere we need to protect the
students so that the mandates cannot be
declared in some future panic
i have two letters from speech
pathologists i have a letter here from
miss reed and miss kolakowski
telling about the how it's making it
difficult for speech pathologists and
learning in general
and uh
well part of learning corrects while
private learning correct speech relies
on seeing the face especially the mouth
and the expression of the person speak
teaching speech
i also have a 29 page
slides from dr petty and he's come here
all the way from vermont
and he's he's going to speak to you as
well
that the harm is done not only in health
but also in learning you'll find the
data there to prove the point
most important point i'd like to make is
the population that was subjected to
this unnecessary burden is the least
likely to incur infection due to
immunity systems at their maximum the
statistics also show zero mortality
among this young group
whoever made the mask mandate did not
pay attention to the infection
statistics
we will like pandemic panic
so please pass this bill so that those
who make decisions on the management of
our schools will not be allowed to
impose this harm on our students
thank you very much for all of you that
came and i'm happy to answer any
questions
thank you very much representative
weiler are there any questions for
representative weiler on on the bill
thank you uh did you have a dr petty
here to
explain uh further technical aspects of
the bill or
he's going to explain he's got this all
the way from vermont right yeah i have
this handout and he's going to
speak to that and i think he has other
handouts as well okay so are there any
questions of representative weiler
not seen thank you very much thank you
and the next representative we have here
is representative melissa blasek
thank you mr chair
uh members of the committee um i'm
melissa plasik uh for the record i
represent hillsborough 21 the town of
merrimack
um i'll keep this really brief um after
the announcement from the governor and
doe wednesday
you might be wondering why this bill is
necessary
new hampshire sba sent a memo yesterday
and i would like to
read some of it um the first part is
just explaining about the announcement
but
if i'm finished with throughout the
pandemic nhsba's position was consistent
with previous statements from the
governor and commissioner that school
boards were free to make their own local
decisions relative to masking
requirements
additionally numerous courts have found
that masking requirements or protocols
are within the purview of local school
boards so as you can see there's some
legal arguments going on with this so
that's why this bill is still
very necessary there are schools
districts currently who are refusing to
drop their mandates as of yesterday
um
and i just want to leave with it's it's
a basic tenet in our society
that we do not place burdens upon
children to protect adults
and this is a tenant that we have
severely lost sight of over the last two
years and as a result
we have damaged a generation emotionally
physically and psychologically
and uh we need to uh reverse course on
this um and we're gonna have an expert
here to discuss why this has all been
very illogical and unscientific and we
have done this to our children so i urge
you all to
otp this bill so that we can put the
nail in the coffin of these mandates
thank you thank you very much are there
any questions representative hopson
thank you mr chair and thank you
representative blasic for being here
i'm not sure that i saw that memo from
the school board association i was
wondering if you could forward it to the
company i will thank you thank you
yes representative cordelli
thank you and thank you representative
for uh coming out in the weather
following up on a comment about children
protecting adults
i was reading an article
yesterday or the day before about a
study
i'm not sure if you had seen it or maybe
someone else has the doctor um of eight
to ten year olds
and it said that they produce one
quarter
of the number of um
viral particles yes
to go along with your statement that
children are
protecting adults
i wonder did you see that study and and
would you have any comments
on that
i don't think i've seen that study in
particular but they've been studying uh
children and covet 19
there's been research since
spring 2020 showing that children are
not significant vectors of transmission
mostly children contract coping 19 from
adults not from other children
so and adults don't typically contract
it from other children as well because
yes they have lower viral loads
yes
thank you
following on to that um one thing i was
always wondering about with the school
mask mandates
the mandates apply to the time the child
is in school
but the child is not in school for a
good portion of time as well and
i am sure that well i'm not sure but i
imagine most parents are not requiring
their children to wear masks
at home
or on weekends so i'm just wondering how
effective
are school mask mandates
thank you for the question um well there
are also studies to suggest that most of
transmission occurs in the household um
you know because obviously that's where
you spend the most amount of time with
other people it's prolonged exposure
that creates that kind of transmission
um
but uh yeah i'm not sure that we're
doing well there there is no research to
suggest that any place with the school
mass mandate had any uh correlation with
reduction in cases or transmission um
and community set in the community at
all so yes i
i don't believe that we have
accomplished
anything i think that this has been very
theatrical
are there further questions from the
representative hobson
thank you mr chair and thanks again for
taking this question um can you tell me
where colleges and universities would
fit into this
um i believe that this bill is only
written for um
k-12
um and it's currently written uh
for public and private um
i'm listen i'm looking to get something
across the finish line if if just making
it public would be okay with with me
certainly um
but um
it could hypothetically be amended to
include public colleges and universities
sure
are there further questions from the
committee
thank you very much representative thank
you
like to invite stephen petty
welcome to new hampshire
thank you and and i
came from south florida so it's a little
further than vermont okay so it's not
just vermont because i was wondering
well
i look over my deck to vermont every day
um
does everyone have the extensive
presentation not the the shorter one but
the longer one
okay those are melissa those are the
ones which are on top of that the green
stack right there
if we have five maybe we can
one going that way one for the file for
you
ribs and cordelia and i will look at
this one here
and then we have
the that's right a couple down that way
who has one
no no this is different no
this is the one that's going to be my
testimony but i'm just going to touch on
about half of them
so you have all the information at hand
we'll have
okay is there an electronic copy of this
that could be sent to us
absolutely yes okay great
go ahead um i wanted to thank uh
chairman rick ladd the committee melissa
for the opportunity to speak especially
given it's snowy um i did grow up in the
mountains uh east of seattle so i
understand that
i'm just going to cover a little bit of
this material but the key high points
that i think are most relevant based on
the questions i've heard
by way of background my name is stephen
petty i've spent most of my career 45
years now believe it or not
involved in protecting the public health
and safety and worker health and safety
i've been named in 400 cases
to protect workers as a
exposure expert exposure control expert
and a pp expert
in fact i'm currently i've testified in
40 cases on the roundup on center
roundup litigation
i testified in kentucky in may to
against the mass mandate as a result of
my testimony the mandate was stricken
statewide so i won't go into any more
background about me there's a lot of
stuff here
and i'm sure you can look me up
i do want to touch basically on the
field of industrial hygiene it sounds
like it's dentistry it's not we have way
too many physicians talking about
industrial hygiene which is the science
associated with anticipation recognition
evaluation control
of things that will make people sick
impair their health
and cause discomfort and even death
and so it's kind of like having your
heart search and do your dentistry they
both may be perfectly capable people but
you want one doing the job and not the
other
and so when i'm in trial testimony we
have physicians talking about
a disease but i'm the exposure expert
and exposure control expert
and i've done that over 400 times named
the other point to be made is that
let's talk a little bit about why mass
cannot and do not work i mean believe me
if i thought mass could do any good
since my whole career has been
protecting the public and public safety
right there unfortunately it takes a
year out of the room for things that
would actually work
so i've got a plot here that shows the
cases in new hampshire over the last two
years and what you see is spikes in the
winter months
i've been involved in cases specifically
one in in michigan federal court on
masking where the
public health official said masking of
the greatest thing we have available to
stop cobit and i said well that's a joke
i said first of all if you look at the
cases in any state or any country
especially in the northern climates they
peak in the winter months and we in
industrial hygiene know why that is
because more people spend time indoors
and that contaminant concentrations are
always greatest indoors as opposed to
outdoors
and if in fact the masts are doing such
a great job you expect cases to drop
with time
you can look at plots as well from
almost any location where mass mandates
were put on and you see after you see
the cases actually rise they don't fall
so that that calls into question that
from from 100 000 feet
you can look at epidemiology work sort
of ground level stuff the best study out
there in a controlled study
despite what people say is a danish
study by vanguard where three thousand
people approximately were put in mass
and three thousand weren't and they
looked at increases in disease
and basically didn't find any
differences
the only other study where you have a
control group that i'm aware of that we
can justify is a case
uh study by oster at all and
specifically they looked at children in
elementary schools it's the only study
i'm
aware of and it's here in my handouts
and they looked at masking of children
no masking of children masking of
teachers no masking and when you when
you look at the data in terms of disease
incidents they fall the lines within
statistical bands fall on top of one
another that means they didn't make a
difference
i've been asked over and over again
about the cdc studies i testified a
month ago in michigan federal court and
i'd looked at all 50 every time i
criticized two or three of their studies
they had a few more the problem is when
you actually read the studies they
suffer from two major faults
one the studies don't have a control
group what do i mean by that if you're
going to say mask work then you better
have as equal a group as you can where
the masks aren't worn and then you look
at the differences
and if there's a difference
then you can make that argument but if
there isn't
you can't well if you don't have a
control group how can you say mass work
or don't work you can't say anything
the other thing is there's confounded
studies meaning that they do a whole
bunch of things at once change air
conditioning social distancing
quarantining masking and they say c
masking made a difference well how do
you carve out the masking component of
that you can't
so to my knowledge there's only been two
or three studies where you actually look
at masks being worn and mass not being
worn
and those studies
show
for sure
on an epidemiological side they don't
work
now if you look at the micro level and i
have a slide in here i use all the time
and it's a cross section of the human
hair
and then i have a little dot on there
that's 10 times the size of a covet
particle
and what i say is that the
diameter of a coveted particle 0.1
microns is on the order of a thousand
times smaller
than the cross-section of human hair and
i ask each of you who wear masks
can you slip a human hair by the side of
your mask especially on either side of
your nose below your eyes
of course you can slip a lot of hairs by
there
and the cobot particle is a thousand
times smaller than that so it's like a
super freeway
you hear this argument about source
control it's garbage
it doesn't care on the super freeway
whether it's going one direction or the
other
if there's big the problem with mass is
you cannot seal them by definition if
they could be sealed they'd be called
respirators we can get into that as well
because there's some movement to n95s
but they're kind of the bottom of the
barrel
excuse me as you're going through that
would you just tell us what page you're
on so we can follow along with you okay
thank you i'm now on um
i was on page 20.
i
apologize other thing i wanted to
let the committee know about is we hear
this argument constantly that droplets
are stopped by masks
it's such a false flag argument it's
like shining light over here when the
argument's over here
edwards and others
have shown that 99.9 of the particles
are actually what we call aerosols less
than 5 microns
so and the problem with with
this is i'm on page 21 moving to page
22. you can look at the settling rate
for example of droplets which are over 5
microns and they're on the order of
minutes
when you look at aerosols then moving to
page 23
the falling time isn't in terms of hours
or minutes it's in terms of days
so these aerosol parts and that's in
still air so if you stir the air up it
stays suspended even longer so the
problem you have these little tiny
particles is it's most of them
in terms of covid and they stay
suspended almost indefinitely
so
and the other thing is that the
literature is clear that these small
particles reach deep into the lung and
that's what causes disease so the masks
don't provide a solution for that the
other thing is and i've said this in
many public testimonies the key is the
gaps around the masks
let's assume the mask is 100 effective
and it's not
if you get anywhere from about up to two
percent of the area of the mask is a gap
you lose 75 percent of whatever
effectives it had if you get to three
percent it's zero effective
i i took my spirit airlines mask and i
actually did an experiment i had nine
percent gap area
three times the zero factor
um so it's the gaps and and uh
there's literature out there that says
you can
and i cite drew nick that says
mass can never be sealed especially when
you're looking at
four to eight hours of wearing these and
we all know that i mean it's just common
sense
so the real so the other thing i hear
once in a while and you should be aware
of this is well it does some good
and i
from a public health and safety
standpoint
as an expert in that area
i would never recommend a solution that
doesn't protect the vast majority of
people and we in our industry have a
requirement that whatever solution we
offer should it offer at least a 90
relative risk reduction in other words
if i'm going to provide a solution that
protects people from asbestos exposure
and asbestosis
do i really want to protect one to 10
percent of the people and let the other
99 to 90 percent get asbestosis of
course not the public would be outraged
and in that analogy by the way the
asbestos particles on average are 50
times larger
than the cobit particle
and what do we do for asbestos workers
we use paprs with sealed asbestos suits
so
there's no way if i was to put people in
mass for asbestos exposures i should
lose every credential i have
so don't get trapped by that argument
well it does one or two percent good
that doesn't it's just not true
on um
page 30 i show the astm standard
um
that just came out on masking
and it says basically we have no
accuracy and no efficacy of
knowing whether they work or not but
when you look at these mass studies a
lot of them
they assume perfectly sealed mask and if
you see the photograph on page 30 it'll
look like that mask is glued to a sheet
of osb or plywood i don't think that's
how people wear their mask to have them
glued with super glue around their face
so even when you look at a can 95 in
their scenario under shaw
which is not a mask
the masks are around 10 percent
effective if they're perfectly sealed or
around zero if they're not
but the kn-95 is around 46 percent
effective
with real gaps around 3.4 do we really
want to have
something that only helps people at that
level of course not from our standpoint
from exposure control we want
engineering controls of dilution
ventilation filtration and destruction
that's what i've been offering i've been
doing for two years and we've actually
implemented a number of schools and it
works
um
just to talk a little bit longer
we're starting to see some religion from
some of the public officials scott
gottlieb on
january 2nd
kind of spilled the beans on cloth masks
and he says it's not going to protect
you he was the former fda commissioner
he said a cloth mask is not going to
protect you from the virus quote unquote
and even cdc on the 14th
said
you know we're not too keen on this mask
anymore maybe you ought to move to an
n95
and i'm on page 34.
so we're told over and over again i've
heard this in court cases follow the cdc
guidance
why i say which guidance on masks i said
it was no mass early 2020 mass 2020 late
2020 no mass summer of 2021 mass fall of
2021 january 14th well we're not too
keen on masks in what world does the
science change 180 degrees
twice
in two years
no science i'm aware of and i was a
senior research scientist at the
national lab
all righty i want to talk just a little
bit about
this
quasi move from mass to n95s
be careful what you do as soon as you
move to a respirator
you have to follow the respiratory
protection standard it requires medical
clearance
you can't wear facial hair
must have a fit test
must have an annual fit test must be
trained
and what's even more disturbing is
and i wrote i wrote a letter to cdc
along with seven others last week
the guidance in the
n95s say quote unquote not for use with
children
yet cdc says you can use them for
it's unconscionable
when the manufacturer says not and it
also says the manufacturer says
well
um you need to follow the respiratory
protection standard so there's some
argument that some people make well the
n95 only has to follow a respiratory
protection standard if it's an employee
employer relationship
and that's technically true
the problem is the manufacturer's
instructions say you've got to follow it
as well whether you're an employee or
not
and god help the person if i'm on the
other side of the table that says oh we
ignored all that and we put our children
in
in respirators and 95s without falling
respiratory protection standard and they
have some health effect as a result of
that
already damaged and harm to children i'm
going to skip ahead to that because
that's of concern to all of us
i'm going to start on page 40
help me
and i'm just going to touch briefly on a
few studies because i want to get to
questions
there's a november 2021 um
i ready understanding student learning
study by curriculum associates
i've i've shown some of the data but if
you moved page 49
for grades 1
through tw um
eight
in
one year twenty to twenty twenty one
reading result outcomes
have dropped
up to nine percent
math
scores have dropped 4 to 10
depending on the grade
if you move all the way to page
the outcomes are even worse for
minorities blacks students that have
predominant black populations latino
where the
degradation and outcomes is anywhere
from 10 to 17 percent
perhaps an even more disturbing study is
this
recent brown university study and i'm
going to move you all the way to page
54.
for children born during the pandemic in
other words somewhere between zero and
one and two years old
they're early learning composite or
various things like number of words they
can speak et cetera at a certain age
their composite score in two years is
down 23 percent
we're doing enormous damage to the
children
and so what did cdc do on february 8th
and that was one of the reasons for my
letter to them
they moved the goal post
they changed learning outcomes so that
outcomes that would be done by say age
24 months or now 30
months so rather than admitting the harm
done they move the goal post
those goal posts have been in place for
18 years by the way
pretty disturbing actually
same study when they looked at
non-verbal and verbal development of
young people
there's a chart on page 55. i won't go
into it but there's a precipitous fall
off from 20 to 2022. it's very
disturbing both on verbal development
and non-verbal development
there was also a january 22
2022 study by the department of
education of england
and i'm on now for you that are
following or trying to follow me
on page
the teacher said that 94
of
the
leaders said that wearing face coverings
made communication more difficult and 59
said it made it a lot more difficult
by the way england has recently dropped
all these mandates
and last but not least i'll cite some
work by keselinski and co-authors from
2021 it begins on page 59
they looked at 1226 studies on the
effects of face masking
distilled it down to 109 qualitative and
44 quantitative
and on page 61 you can see 25 harms done
by mass including
harms done to children both physical and
emotional
so
i i ask you do we really want to put
children and adults in mass the answer
of course is no
i've provided to you in this long
handout
the whole list of engineering controls
we live in what we call the hierarchy of
controls when we try to control hazards
to people and what that is is it was
developed by the national safety council
in 1950
not exactly
recently
and what it says is you you look at
things that are most effective the least
effective and remember i said
engineering controls are the most
effective ppe or met or respirators is
least effective because we know people
won't wear it properly over long periods
of time based on decades of experience
and masks do not fit within the
hierarchy at all
so the solution has always been
dilution ventilation
filtration and engineering controls like
say the new calgon highway which for 400
bucks plus installation covers 6 000
square feet
can get rid of about 90 to 90 percent 95
percent of the viruses including mold
and bacteria per pass
we implemented that technology in a
special needs high school in the fall of
and we had virtually no cases we've had
some with two or three we think those
were brought in
with that i know i've been quick i
apologize but there's a lot of material
here uh we'll make it all available to
you electronically and i appreciate the
opportunity to speak to you and would
take any questions if there's time thank
you very much doctor are there any
questions for dr petty reversing waltz
thank you mr chairman dr petty
i agree with you that it can be
problematic when studies take multiple
factors in
um and then draw a conclusion when
there's really multiple variables there
and i'm wondering if you're familiar
with the study by stamford and yell out
of bangladesh at dealing with masks i am
so that was a single factor study as i
recall the only difference between those
villages was masquerading and unmasking
isn't that correct
it's not actually
it's stated that way but i think you'll
find there and i can give you at least
four or five analysis that say the state
study is fatally flawed there's there's
two areas one there's there's really
not well established control non-control
group
the only way they really knew people
were wearing them or not is they had
people standing on corners essentially
like policemen make trying to make sure
they wore them and they were also
compensating people to wear them
that's not typically done the other
thing is they didn't really know who had
disease and who didn't because they
didn't have a line in the sand
as to when that sterile presence in the
blood actually occurred
so there's enormous criticisms of that
study in the literature right now
in fact most
i would say most epidemiologists
and i can hand you three or four
articles that say that
are
really against that study
so you're suggesting that some of our
top scientists there
didn't come up with an honest study
i'm not saying anything about their
honesty i'm saying and i'm not i don't
even know if i agree with you that
they're top scientists the people
actually doing the work i don't think
they're top scientists
there are some people here in the united
states that looked at that work and
published on it but when you bore into
the data you find it's got serious flaws
so i have another question for you would
you agree with me that correlation is
not causation
um
it's kind of a yes or no answer
i mean
the difference the difference is you're
looking at epidemiology versus
industrial hygiene
we're in the world of erring on the side
of public health and safety by that i
mean though
um
if we see
trends
because remember i said the definition
of industrial hygiene is anticipation
recognition evaluation and control
then we will take some actions to try to
protect the public but those actions
have to have
the ability to protect the vast majority
of people not a minority of people the
issue of uh
correlation
versus causation is very complex
and it's really beyond the ability to
deal with that in a short time sure but
it's not there's not a simple tie that
correlation is not always causation you
can have correlation and in fact there's
no causation relationship is that not
correct
you give me a specific example answered
i i i think that sometimes sometimes you
can have correlation and there's no
relationship to causation
uh
are you telling me correlation is always
causation i'm not saying we need to make
it a question we're gonna get there well
we're trying to lay the foundation
in what context i mean i can i
i can tell you that i've looked at uh
probably 500 studies on benzene related
to leukemia
so
there's both correlation and causation
but here's the problem what you're
headed towards is is this idealistic
assumption that
you do you don't do anything or you
don't do the proper things unless you
have causation that's not how we operate
and you'll say okay well we wore mass to
do that no mass never had a chance of
being a solution to this problem you're
anticipating the wrong question so
you're ducking this because you're
anticipating the wrong question where
i'm going with this is you started
talking about masking and you started
talking about the drop and the
performance of our kids in schools
and i would maintain the correlation
there's a correlation there when kids
were master they dropped
but i think this the reason kids
performance dropped is not because they
were marrying masks there are so many
things that have happened under covid
and that it's not just masking it's the
stress on the kids it's the remote
learning it's time at home it's time
away from the classroom it's just
you know you any element early
elementary teacher right now will tell
you that the kids are unusually needy
and they're not performing like they
used to and they particularly the early
grades k12 have never known
um a normal school year and so you came
in and testified that
these kids were masked and all of a
sudden all their performances dropped
and they were you testified as if there
was a correlation there we need it
that's what i'm suggesting so the
question is would you agree that there's
not a direct correlation between math
squaring and student performance
no i wouldn't agree with that at all
there are there are multiple factors in
some of the studies and some of the
studies are cider masking only there's
no doubt that masking it has an impact
on on learning i cited the english
department of education study which is
purely masking
so how can you say that
we're not we're not going to go any this
is not i'm not in the courtroom here
but i'm just going to say one final
question if i may and that is how can
you say that there was one factor there
when we all know there were so many
factors going on during covid
how can i say that there's no there's no
doubt and there's no doubt based on the
evidence that masking is like there are
other factors as well i've not said that
but masking you cannot deny that masking
is one of those factors
you just made thank you
thank you very much
thank you
okay are there any further questions
from the committee i want to remind the
uh public that's coming in that we do
have an overflow room across the hallway
where it's being streamed
and for those that are we and we do have
a limit capacity in this room so that's
set by the fire marshal so that's not us
setting that limit and we're getting
close to it
so if if in fact we get many more in
maybe perhaps after some have testified
you could go across and listen and give
the opportunity for those coming in
further questions
rep
representative lykas
thank you
i have heard that in that study that you
quoted that mega stud or over study
where they took all of those studies and
then
picked uh you know narrowed it down to a
certain number i have heard people say
that well yeah they were just
cherry-picking
the ones that had the results they
wanted so what can you tell us about
that
well i think when you look at
epidemiology meta studies are on the top
of the pyramid right
by definition so that's a meta study so
that's that's always the argument made
that that for somebody doesn't agree
with the outcome
and
you know the question i always ask him
is what what specifically was cherry
picked because i don't believe that's
the case i think they were they were
they were honest in the paper about what
studies they picked and why
further questions thank you
representative hopson
thank you mr chair and thank you for
being here i appreciate it um i have a
question for you bring it down a couple
of notches i'm not going to get into you
know studies and things but can you tell
me the cdc it
i was i wasn't following you um after
your discussion of masks and the changes
back and forth but what are the current
recommendations right now
i thought there was some sort of
change
in whether or not they were closely
fitted or not closely fitted can you
can you bring that back to
to current thank you yeah
i'll quote you the language it's on
january 14th and january 28th
they say loosely woven cloth products
provide the least protection
and then they say
niosh approve respirators
which is interesting then they say
including n95s because respirators can
go all the way to scbas right i mean
they can go to scott air packs the
firemen things
offer the highest level of protection
this is tacit admission that the cloth
mass don't work
yes
so that is the current
recommendation right now
the the current recommendation is to
move towards n95s yes
the problem with that of course is
that when you when you look at further
guidance
it it's it says they can be used on
children and then they provide links to
the manufacturers at 3m
moldex others
websites
with their limitations in their
paperwork
the paperwork says not for use with
children
that's what's so
disturbing
further question representative
thank you miss sharon thank you dr petty
for being here given the circumstances
and the weather and and uh
where you live
so
in
new hampshire as i you're well aware
there's a phase out that we're going
through right now in terms of new
guidance if you will from from the state
however
as i understand the school buses are
not
under federal
jurisdiction
federal travel so my understanding is
that
kids on school buses will still have to
wear masks even if the school districts
drop their mask mandates my question is
given your background in all your
travels and your connections do you have
any sense if the feds will let the
students take their masks off on buses
um
my sense is that they're going to lag
because the whole reason and we we know
from from actual documents
that the reason cdc went from no mass to
mass in the fall of 2021
was pressure from the teachers union
um
that's just a statement of fact
um so there are political things driving
this i've always said this isn't a
science issue this is a political issue
the the reason i think it's important
that the legislature and i've been
talking to a lot of groups
put something in place like this is
you're going to have this scenario where
the next time there's some
incident that they believe is important
politically then they'll just just like
they did in the fall of 2021 they'll
slap the mass thing on again
i i think that uh that it needs to
follow the science
the actual science and um
and then if we're gonna if we're gonna
do something like that
especially if you look at the guidance
from who the world health organization
they say for children in order to
put masks or anything on children you
have to do a
risk analysis meaning what are the
benefits minus what are the costs or
liabilities
the costs in terms of learning
emotional
development
physical harm
those have never been compared to
at cdc or anywhere else
the benefits which i think the benefits
are almost zero
so
that the thing that's important is that
we get back to the science and the
legislature not let people simply
mandate things that don't have real
signs behind them
thank you
further questions
supposed to be about education
i've talked to a lawyer who has
testified federally
for a number of years about
immunizations
and is very interested in this topic and
it seems that all the schools that have
imposed mask mandates are relying on cdc
guidance or similar
health
recommendations
but this lawyer points out that they
have ignored
education impact
which is their primary function
so i was interested in seeing some of
the studies you have here but
i think the point is that
protecting health is certainly
a responsibility but also education and
you have to look at the education impact
the cost benefit
of mandates such as this
do you have any
thoughts on that
absolutely the
as i said i've cited in this
presentation and others
the world health organization's unicef's
position on masking and children
and they all say that you need to do
this this i'll call it risk assessment
or cost benefit analysis before you do
it in fact their primary
mantra is do no harm
and the harms
are not accounted for in the united
states yet in any formal analysis that
i'm aware of so i absolutely agree with
you
thank you
represent luno
thank you very much mr chair and thank
you very much
uh mr petty for uh
being here with us this morning um i was
just um uh uh interested to learn a
little bit more about um
your um uh the work that you do
providing uh expert opinions
uh as part of your uh your professional
career and um you're not wearing an
orange badge in that in new hampshire
that means that um when you're wearing
an orange badge badge somebody has uh
has paid for you to
to provide testimony i was wondering if
anybody
is
is compensating you for your travel and
testimony here this morning and who that
organization might be
um
i would say of the several
thousand people that i've helped i've
taken
to this point i've taken no compensation
i figure i've donated almost a half a
million of my time
in one case where i presented in
nebraska they paid my airfare and they
paid a hotel for the night that i had to
stay over in this case
i'm paying for everything but i have
there has been some crowdsourcing that
has donated some money to help with the
airfare because my first flight got
cancelled and i had to pay for a very
expensive second flight to get here
um whether i take that money or not i
don't know but so far i've not taken any
money
no thank you
any further questions of dr petty
yes
just follow follow up with that with the
crowd sourcing was that from an
organization or
who did the crowd sourcing
um i'm not sure that was that was uh i
was gone by that point and they worked
through my wife i'll have to check
no we're not going to have anybody in
the crowd responding to that thank you
any further questions from the committee
thank you very much doctor thanks so
much for the opportunity to testify
uh what i'm going to do now because
we're starting to get a whole lot more
cards and then when we started out we're
going to limit the testimony to three
minutes i have some coming in parking
down 10 minutes more than that
um
so it's not uh it's very typical and
normal that we do limit time so we're
gonna start timing and it'd be about
three minutes per per person so if you
have testimony again if it's written
testimony would you please submit the
written testimony and not necessarily
read it to us because we can also take
the time and we will to read any
testimony that's provided to us so i'd
like to go ahead and invite joanna brown
hello and thank you
my name is joanna brown from manchester
new hampshire
maths don't work and there is a mountain
of scientific studies to prove that i
have given this evidence to the
manchester school board back in
september and they ignored it
they ignored us
every meeting we were there citing the
evidence and they've ignored us
there is no science behind mass stopping
airborne viruses such as covid but there
are not numerous dangers to our kids
from wearing masks all day
i have three children in high school
kovit is with us forever
it's just like the flu and keeping
physical distancing and improved
ventilation is fantastic there are no
side effects to that but there are side
effects to wearing a mask all day
especially for our youngest population
mass don't help they hurt
it is very hard to read emotions when
someone covers their face facial cues
and visual expressions are part of body
language that we learn as a very young
age
reading lips is an integral part of
speech development for your very young
children
constant mask wearing is slowing their
progress and i believe some testimony
has been submitted by the speech and
language therapists in new hampshire
reporting this damage that's being done
constant mask wearing interrupts into
personal relations for older children as
well mass cause anxiety for teenagers
because they can't tell whether someone
is smiling at them or frowning at them
and this is critical for teenagers that
are going through
some very big emotional turmoil right
now about when life will ever return to
normal
a nurse who spoke at one of the last
manchester school board meetings
gave some very moving testimony
she is on the front lines in the
hospitals and she is seeing a huge spike
in er visits from teenagers suffering
from depression and suicide attempts
there is something seriously going wrong
in our school system
it is time to make mass optional and
return to normal vaccines and masking is
still possible for anyone with a high
risk
this is a parental decision not a state
or a school board decision
masking as a psychological mechanism to
scare our kids will be easier to control
when they grow up
if they make it that far
and the
hypocrisy is
causing greater frustration and
confusion for these kids they watch on
tv with a super bowl and no one's
wearing a mask and then they have to go
back to school the next day and wear a
mask all day
and they get told by their teachers some
of them not so kindly that they're going
to kill somebody if they don't wear
their mask properly
there is some really awful things going
on in the school system and nobody is
paying attention to it
let's stop these health mandates before
they divide us any further
please vote to make mass optional in all
schools our kids who have no serious
risk of covid should never be mandated
to wear one just to get an education
not ever again
thank you thank you very much all right
well you'll take any questions
are there any questions from the
committee yes representative luno
uh thanks very much thanks for uh for
joining us uh this morning you mentioned
that um or your testimony said covid is
the same as the flu i was wondering if
you could um
speak to that as it relates to mortality
rate
i'm not referring to mortality rates i'm
talking about the prevalence of
the flu the flu is with us every year it
varies from year to year and that's what
they're predicting covid to be right a
new virus a new variant is going to come
out every year
and like the last omicron variant that
just came out
it was very contagious
but it was nothing more than a head cold
for most people who got it
yes would you would you believe that the
more mortality rate for coven 19
is uh is an order of magnitude greater
than mortality rate for the flu i think
the death reporting rates are
questionable
i think many people were reported to die
with covid when they simply died with
something else and
contracted covid when they were in the
hospital i think early treatment for
kovid did not happen
and many deaths could have been
prevented if we had health care had
acted differently in the beginning of
covid
i think there are a lot of big questions
about the death rates
of kovid
that still have to be answered
are there further questions from the
committee
thank you very much
i'd like to invite catherine smith
if you could press the silver button
i'd just like to refocus that the bill
is about prohibiting school boards and
accredited non-public schools from
adopting enforcing or implementing
policies that require students or
members of the public to wear face
coverings i don't want to address the
efficacy of masks
and i just kind of have to
um
i'd like to start with the axiom that
federal funding is the tail that was the
dog
and
my name is catherine smith i'm a
registered nurse with a bachelor's in
science
and i worked in community health for the
last seven years
i've spent many many hours researching
the efficacy of masks the benefits the
benefits versus the detriment the
violations if any to human rights civil
rights
i've made pleas along with other parents
for school board members to consider the
mass mandates as unacceptable for our
school-age boys and girls
collectively along with myself and other
parents as i've watched um different
testimonies to school board members and
i've written down the site you know
the laws and things that they were
citing as violations and i researched
those lots of times things were
i agree taken out of context or had
already been tried in the courts and um
and ruled on
but these laws ranged from natural law
to hay conventions humanitarian
conventions
all over the spectrum
and then i i've read parts of the uh the
essa grants and some
copies of applications
and
within the process i found that
this in the application process the
schools when they were applying for the
s grants the schools were required to
lay out
a safety plan on how they were going to
provide a safe environment and
this included lots of
schools stating that they would
refer to the department of health and
human services or the cdc guidelines
and so
i have here that the role of the
the school board
is it exists to provide appropriate
educational opportunities for our
students
and it should be prior
prioritized by what is best for the
student and what enhances the student
achievement
as a
parent in the community dealing with the
situation i would go to many school
board meetings and we would offer our
opinions and ask the school board to
make their decisions based on our
concerns but every meeting they went
back to the metrics of the guidelines
for
masking based on case numbers and based
on
the hospital capacity so for somehow
that just didn't seem to me that it was
in the best sense of the student and
that's where they were directing their
attention
so also in my research i came across
this very interesting document that was
put together in 2009
and it was about state the state
sovereignty movement and child welfare
and the um
the goal of this this document was to
inform
the state legislators of the concerns of
these people based on
uh child welfare and communist goals the
cold war era
and there was a included federal child
welfare laws a plea for justice yeah
you've gone by your three minutes now
if you have materials that you're
looking at you could submit those
materials
okay i would just like to i would just
like to make the connection so that i
don't seem like i was just rambling but
somewhere along the line we have to
accept that under contemplate that our
children are being exploited for federal
funding the esr grants have brought in
millions of dollars into these schools
under the guise of their public health
and safety
and
nobody's even sure of the efficacy of
the masks
and that needs to be evaluated how much
federal funding are we allowing to come
in and to control the situation
by accepting these this money
and taking away our sovereignty as
parents who elect school board members
and as as citizens of the state thank
you very much are there any questions
from the committee thank you very much
for coming today
nicole souza
hi my name is nicole souza and i drove
here in the snowstorm from amherst
i have poured over hundreds or thousands
of hours spending time on covid so if
you have any questions about any studies
including the bangladesh study or the
fatality rate you can ask me after but
i'd like to focus on
my personal experience with the schools
in september 2020 i was put in a very
difficult position should i pull my son
out of a private school that my family
has loved and cherished for years
or
should i uh
when i'm a full-time working
parent
or should i force him to cover his face
all day long
i agonized over the choice every day i
dream about moving somewhere where my
son can breathe free
i think about all the millions of kids
around the world including australia
denmark sweden uk
where they never match children under
12.
they get to see their teachers smile
their voices are not muffled
they can feel the fresh air on their
beautiful cute faces
they are told that school is safe school
is a safe and happy place
they get to talk to their friends at
lunch and laugh
all mine is forced to eat inside in
silence
or sit outside in the cold or the rain
because they have to take off their
masks
instead of breathing fresh air and
feeling it on his skin
he has to feel the heat and moisture
all day
he can't see his feet when he walks
because as you know the mass impacts
your vision
he doesn't even know what his teacher's
face looks like
his teacher saw the yearbook photos and
said
wow they're so cute
because she's never seen their faces
facial expressions were the primary
human language long before verbal
language
mealtime socialization has been a
primary part of human civilization
forever
what are we doing to our children
why are the most restrictions on the
least at-risk group
why are we experimenting on our children
with these new devices that they've
never
worn before
we haven't done one randomized control
trial on children
shouldn't the burden should be on the
intervention to prove safety and
efficacy it shouldn't be on us to prove
harm
we should have when you're being forced
any experiments which this is an
experiment because we have never done it
before
should require informed consent which
means that we should not be coerced by
school administrations who are under
pressure by people that have used fear
as a virtue
parents have had enough
it's time if some parents today are
lucky that their children in mount new
hampshire get their masks off mine
doesn't
i could choose to take just about at the
end of your time
you are at 10 of your time okay thanks
um
it's causing conflict in our schools
and uh
it's time to give the power back to the
parents give back informed consent
bring back smiles and never let this
happen to our children again you want
this to be on our children you should
show it in
excellent research with randomized
controlled trials like we've done every
other intervention thank you thank you
very much are there questions from the
committee
not seeing any hands thank you very much
for coming today
maureen hardy h-a-r-d-y i believe
um before i start
this is just some of my materials
i did not hand out
printed out materials i will email it
because there are links
to citations to studies
and other information that is very
important to understand
can i start now yes go ahead
thank you thank you for allowing me to
testify my name is maureen hardy from
londonderry i'm testifying in favor of
this bill i've worked in the clinical
microbiology lab for 26 years
participated in the infection control
test group for my hospital including
ambulatory care settings i have worked
in r d for diagnostic devices and i've
worked in the pharma industry and
pharmacovigilance i have taught clinical
microbiology at the community college
level and medical ethics at the
university level i have a master's
degree in epidemiology
when evaluating mitigation strategy for
a disease whether from the perspective
of a pharmaceutical product or a public
health policy the risk benefit analysis
must be considered
based on multiple studies and population
data the risk benefit analysis does not
support the use of facial mass for the
prevention of covet 19 especially for
children
the wearing of facial masks does not
prevent the transmission of respiratory
viruses for example sars cove ii
and i have several studies that i'll
email you and by today's testimony
children are extremely low risk of bad
outcomes from the infection with sars
cove 2 with a zero percent death rate
per the cdc since january 1st 2020 and i
pulled that data yesterday from the cdc
website wearing masks is not a benign
intervention and causes serious and
potentially long long term damage to
children
mask worrying causes physical
psychological and social damage to
children we also know that masks
encourage mouth breeding in children
which leads to facial deformities masks
interfere with the children learning
socially through facial expressions
speech learning is lost in the very
young learning deficits have been
observed in all an israeli-canadian
study published in cognitive research in
february 2022 found that masks disrupt
holistic processing and face perception
in school-aged children
masks keep other pathogens trapped near
the mouth and nose in the lungs of
children these are larger pathogens and
include bacteria mold and parasites
finally children need to be free
to be exposed to the natural environment
to keep their immune system strong
therefore the risk benefit analysis does
not support the use of facial masks as a
public health mitigation strategy
especially for school children there is
zero benefit and high risk the mask
recommendations were put into place by
national and local public health
agencies without evidence of benefit and
with and without evaluation of risks and
followed by school boards and
administrators who had nother no other
sources of guidance
we now have 2020 hindsight and
understand that masking children is
wrong let us correct this now and not
put the school boards in the position of
having to mandate bad policy ever again
there is a fear of a more lethal covet
virus arriving around the world but the
spread of another respiratory virus also
would not be mitigated by a mask wearing
i wish that masks worked but i know that
they don't
i'll stop there thank you very much
other questions represent hobson
thank you mr chair and thank you for
being here today um i have two questions
first one is you said you worked with
pathogens
yes and did you wear a mask while you
were working with those pathogens
i worked with patient samples and for
the most part i did not wear a mask but
when i was working with mycobacterium
tuberculosis which causes tuberculosis
and pathogenic fungi
i wore an n95 mask and per ocean
regulation i had to be fit tested
annually and trained but in addition
i was wearing a gown and gloves i was
working in a biological safety cabinet
and a negative pressure
room
so these are not the type of
interventions that are realistic for a
school child in addition the n95 masks
are not approved for the use in children
and the particles that i'm working that
i was working with are specifically
mentioned
by the package insert for the mask
and um
it specifically says that
smaller particles like
viruses
are there's no rec there's no
recommendation for those in the in the
package insert only it specifically
mentions mycobacteria tuberculosis and
mold and it also mentions bacillus
anthracis
second question was um
i did not know i i didn't
yeah i did not know that uh breathing
through your mouth could cause physical
dysphor deformity is that what you said
yes this has been this has been known
for a long time
so i do have a link to that study and i
i will email it to um
to you all
any further questions from the committee
represent yes represent
thank you mr chair um i have a question
if somebody has coveted
and they're wearing a mask
does that have a detrimental effect
potentially because you're not getting
as much oxygen as you normally would
um
well
i'm not a physician so i i can't answer
that i could just tell you what what i
believe
you're probably re-breathing to some
extent i mean a lot of it is coming out
the sides
and the top of the mask and the pores of
the mask but you're probably
re-breathing
um
a lot of it and therefore you are
re-inoculating yourself with the virus
so that more virus can multiply in your
nose and throat and go to your lungs so
it's probably a bad idea
thank you very much
other questions from the committee
thank you very much for coming today
i have a card here looks like it's reed
lambert and is tricia
lamp are you both on the same
okay two of you for coming
party
yeah
thank you mr chair and the committee
thank you
um
as mentioned i brought my son reed here
it's by no mistake that his name is reed
because he has a reading disability
and i
i'm going to make this short i think
we've talked about the efficacy and i
think we have a lot of experts here that
have covered that so i i'd like to make
this more of a witness um
statement of exactly what is happening
to these children
and reid is a perfect example of that
um reed has had a reading disability
since um
was
noted in in first grade he's had
wonderful teachers
in fact when he went to um
school and by the way we're in the
hopkinton school district
he had a
language teachers
that spend a tremendous amount of time
with him to
learn how to read because he is a
short-term memory issue
and one of the things that they told us
was what was already stated is that the
moving of the mouth
and actually
showing they actually would draw this on
the board repeatedly
was so important for him to understand
how to pronounce
the english language
this this went on
through um his um he was that he's now
in ninth grade he is homeschooled
um so as you can imagine with a
disability has an iep or an
individualized
education
program for himself
that um he was one unable to wear a mask
and the school actually approved that in
the spring of last year in may of last
year and he did not have a mask now
there were other issues that i took
that i felt were still incorrect and not
good for his welfare
like playing a drum in a closed off room
by himself with the band outside
in the other room on a drum that didn't
really work
i mean this is what they're
relinquishing them to segregating them
over into other locations
but he did was maskless um because we
did not
allow it anymore and it was by the way
in his iep that coven needed
to be addressed in any way shape or form
so
going to
forward into the next year
the esser funds came into play yes or
three so if you're familiar with those
um sr3 as they had mentioned as others
had testified pretty much made them
follow the cdc guidance and it was very
clear by our school board we had to be
there 180 days
that was the goal
so every child had to wear a mask
so
in the sense that he already was
masculist and had approved was
relinquished
so so here we have a child who has
trouble reading
being unable
to
have the proper care that he needs to
learn
so
the long short of it is is that
the esr funds are driving
drove exactly these decisions our school
boards are not meant to make medical
decisions for our children i was advised
by the superintendent i'll finish up
i was advised by the superintendent that
i did not have the ability to um i gave
them do not consent letters for both of
my children
and i was unable to not consent as a
parent they can't put bug spray on them
but they can put a mask across their
face in order to breathe
there's something not right here
i
i respectfully ask that you
vote in support of this bill
it's important so that masks never go on
our children again without their parents
consent
um
and um
the other thing is real quick is the
state website i think we talked about
the mortality
the state website lacks that it calls it
one percent um i actually looked it up
this morning number of co people who had
coveted versus those who have died and
it's 99.9305
so what exactly how
of people that have recovered from
coveting did not pass away so it's
99.993 at what point
do we
um
look at this and say what is the what is
the benefit of wearing a mask on a child
for seven hours a day
thank you i'll be happy to say thank you
very much are there any questions from
the committee yes representative
cordelli
uh thank you mr chairman uh thank you
for coming in today um i just wanted to
make sure i understood um what you were
saying about
reed's iep
um
did the iep say that
he could be maskless
and that that was rescinded
at some point
or did the iep did you have a new iep
meeting that changed the iep or did they
just say regardless of the iep he has to
wear a mask
thank you good question so
we when he the mask came off his face in
may of 2021
it was a correspondence back and forth
with the superintendent at that time
and
they agreed to take off the mask
the language did not specifically state
match but it did have language regarding
covet and that they would do anything to
address his issues as it related to his
to his learning
so
i think that answers the majority of the
question so
um
in the new in the new year we were
pretty much told after we sent the do
not consent letters
that we didn't have the right to do not
consent
and then i explained the iep i said he's
been not he's had it off all summer
because he has summer school
and they said
um
um they said the board had voted which
they didn't to um
to put masks back on their faces and
that he had to wear one and that i would
have to go through the whole process all
over again
thank you
representatives
you you said at some point that he was
homeschooled did that happen after i
mean can you explain that sure
so the beginning of the year um once we
were told that they had to wear a mask i
also have a daughter who also attended
she's a junior
we walked in every day with the attempt
to try to
to go to school and i said they're here
but they will not wear a mask and say
suspended them
because they would not wear a mask so i
refused to allow them to be targeted
sitting in a room somewhere
whether it's the library or wherever
they had us we're going to assign them
and i took them home we did that for
approximately 15 15 days
and then
finally i wrote the letter to homeschool
them
thank you very much
thank you are there further questions
from the committee
not seeing any hands thank you very much
thank you
thanks for coming
amy thompson
welcome amy
i don't know what i'm doing
um i just wanted to quickly
i live on the seacoast
and the governor's orders we all cheered
thank goodness
they got rid of the mass in my son's
school
but the day before
i attended a
school board meeting
and it was an emergency session meeting
that they had called about the masks
so the room was full
and
before anybody spoke from the parents
or a teacher came as well to tell them
the impact
on the students that she sees daily they
come into the classroom
some don't even speak they hide behind
their mask
they look at the floor she tries to
engage them with her eyes and they don't
even look up
the children have been hiding behind the
mask some of them don't
teenage years are difficult
some people who are introverts it's
their
safety to have a mask on
so
i i attended the school board meeting to
listen to what people had to say and i'm
glad i went
unfortunately the school board didn't
listen to the parents or the teacher
they voted even before they listened
they said they were going to keep the
masks
nobody
and then they
said public comment
the parents were horrified
and so at the end when they had all
listened
and and the parents didn't understand
what was going on
and someone said wait wait aren't we
going to debate are you going to listen
to us and
maybe talk amongst yourselves the school
board one of them said i call for an
adjournment
and the rest of them all
agreed and they said it's adjourned
so i just want to say that they're not
interested um where i am in data
i listen to the expert
they i've set numerous emails
telling them of the data that's out
there about the masks and we can debate
whether you think they're effective or
not i don't think they are but
they don't want to listen at all
so i think you need to vote for this
so that you can protect my child
because they obviously don't have his
best interest at heart or at least i
don't think so
that's all
representative cordelia thank you you're
willing to take questions sure i guess
thank you um i just wanted to make sure
i understood what she said um at that
board meeting you attended
um the board discussed the mask
requirement and voted to require masks
before public comment and hearing from
parents is that correct that's correct
thank you
and what is the school district is it
sau
so i live in stratham but my um son
lives with his father and lives in um
it's um
we know okay thank you further further
questions yes representative waltz
yes um so you testified that you think
the school district did not have your
son's best interests at heart
and i
listen to everybody i'm hearing what
you're saying but i also heard from a
constituent of mine
whose son has severe respiratory
problems and needs at least during covey
needed the people around him masked he's
a child who's probably hospitalized one
month a year with respiratory issues
and and getting covered could possibly
have killed him given his severe
respiratory issues so you've got school
districts with these kids he happens to
be a senior in high school that have
these severe respiratory issues that
need protecting and then you've got
children like yours
what do you propose a district does to
find the balance between somebody who
doesn't want their child masked and
somebody who is life and death whether
or not their child is masked um i just
have a question does that chat what does
that child do during the regular cold
and flu season isn't that a detrimental
risk to his health can he get pneumonia
and i don't know his personal the answer
is it's happened to him so yes that's a
serious problem so then what do they do
then what was the answer then send them
to school
well then i don't i don't see the
difference and i will say
my other son has asthma
and he can't wear a mask
and he can't play basketball because
they make him wear a mask if he wants to
play basketball and he can't go to
regular school
so what do you suppose my son should do
who can't wear a mask what's he supposed
to do i had to homeschool him so i don't
and i've i i understand that you have an
opinion and i get that but there comes a
time where i will say
if that is the policy and if you're
going to tell me you know what's really
funny they didn't tell you the policy
until way bef like five minutes before
last year that they were gonna require
masks so then i was supposed to scramble
and try to find somewhere for my child
to go to school why was that why didn't
they tell us in june why didn't they
tell us in july when i could have found
a place for him to go to school
what was the story there so i understand
you have an opinion i have an opinion
and there's gonna come a time where i'm
gonna say no more i'm gonna say no more
i don't i don't have to send them to
public school
so that that's that's the reality
and i wish that they would listen more
all i was trying to point out is that
school districts are getting pulled from
both sides
and
it's not that i have an opinion at this
point it's that
you indicated that the school district
just didn't care and what i'm suggesting
is they care they're just getting pulled
from both sides and that was the point
of that story
um
so the winneconnet school principal
last month there was a basketball game
rival
and so he decided it was a good idea to
make a difference between 850 kids and a
thousand kids
in a um basketball court
what could that have possibly made a
difference so my question to him was
fine i get that you're trying to come up
with some sort of visual restriction so
it looks like you're doing something i
understand
what are you going to do with the kids
that didn't get a ticket
do you have some sort of
consolation prize for someone who didn't
get a ticket now see that tells me that
he did not care for those kids at all
because he said nope sorry you didn't
get a ticket even though they've not
been able to go to things and been
restricted and all this other why didn't
he have an answer why didn't he give
them a consolation prize why did they
have to sit home and not have a ticket
i don't i don't understand so when they
say they don't have the best interest i
don't think
they're trying to have a visual
thing that says we're doing something
well sometimes that visual thing is
causing harm
so that's my answer i don't i don't know
what you know
representative moffatt
thank you mr and thank you for being
here taking the time on a day like this
to um to come here to concord you
mentioned basketball a couple of times
in the context of your sign and then
later
with regard to the gems my question
could you amplify that a little bit when
you say
uh
he
couldn't wear a mat or had to wear a
mask while playing basketball was this
an intramural situation a pe situation
or a team situation could you explain
that a little bit um so um
my older son lives in hampton and i live
in stratham
so in stratum
they use the um basketball town for the
school you they use the school gym some
of the towns have decided that they're
not going to do that they go to um the
rim
facility and i don't believe they
require mass for them to wear during
um playing
so this was town so i signed him up and
i didn't know
that they were going to require masks
so um i signed him up and then the night
before we were supposed to go to tryouts
he um they sent out an email that said
just to let you know all masks are
required and i thought well maybe they
just mean for me
and he could play
so then i
uh emailed the town
administrator for the recreation and she
said no really sorry but
the schools require you to wear a mask
during playing of basketball
and i said well he can't
can't wear him he gets an anxiety attack
so
i said he can't so she said oh i'm
really sorry but and we'll refund your
money
follow up yes
uh thank you the concrete monitor had a
photo of a basketball
game where one player was guarding a
player one player was masked and the
other player was not so
does winner kind of do you know does to
the teams
yeah i'm trying to hear you so does
winner kind of have a
requirement for the players and their
teams to where mastering games are you
know you know what i don't think they do
for winneconne but i think when they
went to portsmouth they had two
i'm not 100 positive um but
the older kids i think are probably a
little bit more um difficult to make do
things
so they would just wear them on their
chin
thank you
further questions
not seen thank you very much
marie fontaine
hi good morning good morning um thanks
for having me um
i was gonna speak to a few things that
have already been covered so i'll just
kind of skip that
but the doctor earlier did mention
industrial masking and i did want to
comment quickly on that i worked in lead
abatement in manchester for about two
years
we had to have half face respirators
with cartridges
i need to do a fit test medical
clearance
the fit test included you know smoke to
make sure that it was fitted to your
face properly a proper seal
i was trained in mass cleaning and
maintenance
so when i saw that there were mass
requirements for kids with the cloth
masks i was really confused because i
was just like this doesn't make sense to
me
um so
that's just a comment on some of my
experiences with
masking industrial masking and so seeing
kids wear these cloth masks hasn't made
sense to me for a while
seeing in manchester walking by the
public schools and watching kids outside
running and playing with their mask on
also doesn't make sense to me the world
health organization counsels against
masking kids during physical activities
so as not to compromise their breathing
so i don't understand why we're doing
this in the united states
the other thing i wanted to comment on
science briefs published by the cdc show
that most transmission in schools is
staff to staff rather than transmission
from students to staff
so
children are low risk they're not high
transmitters
i don't this is another thing that
doesn't make sense to me um
and this is something we've known for a
long time and it's been two years and
it's still happening
so it's gone on long enough it's
egregious um it's wrong
it's security theater
so i'm asking that we put a stop to this
and we prevent it from happening again
so i'd like
these bills to be supported those are my
comments thank you thank you very much
for coming are there questions from the
committee
not seeing you thank you
bruce ann
i haven't seen you in about a week
welcome welcome
thank you committee chair thank you
community members i want to personally
say i really appreciate the fact that
all of you are here um as you can see
this is something that's um important to
all of us and i would just ask that you
folks that are reading and doing stuff
on your computer please stop and listen
to us
thank you
um
because i think this is important i
think this is really important the
bottom line here is when
when um excuse me
i'll go on
thank you um the bottom line here is our
children have been abused for the last
two years we have we have watched
and allowed
for our children to be emotionally
abused you've heard testimony about the
emotional abuse that's going on i want
to talk a little bit about what it feels
like for someone of a domestic violence
situation or a child who has been
physically or emotionally or abused
sexually abused to have to put a mask on
their face
just think about that i want all of you
to go home tonight and do this
because that's what the mass feels likes
to these children
we talk about reactive attachment
disorder we talk about risk costs
benefit analysis risk cost benefit
analysis this is our children
this is tomorrow's future and it's just
a mask remember when it was just a mask
for all of us and now it's keep moving
that goal post i made over 3 000 masks
from my town alone so our children could
be masked
it was only for two weeks
how long has it been now
how long has it been and the school
boards and the school districts are not
do not for the most part have our
children's best interest at heart i
don't have any children in the school
systems right now thank god and my
grandchildren have my my daughter has
chosen to homeschool her
grandchildren home school my
grandchildren again i am thankful
i don't i have gone to now 14 different
school boards and just watched
and observed the way that parents are
being treated and the way that in
some instance look around
look around to you folks the people that
are paying attention and the people are
not
okay the bottom line here is we are
being we are we've been told kids aren't
the problem the parents are
shouldn't that be a problem for us
it's too soon to really know how much
damage we've done to our children we
can't just know that it's just masks
it's a lot of other stuff too how about
we just stop doing damage how about that
um other cultures other cultures that
require masking or hiding of the face
they have been dehumanized women who are
forced to keep this
it's so much easier to kill someone
when you can't exceed their expression
it's so much easier to disallow and
dehumanize someone when all you can see
is this
it's not okay
and i know this is just a mask but we
need to start taking our schools and our
school districts and our school boards
back we need to start saying no more we
are the parents we these are our
children these are not the school boards
children these are not our towns
children
these are our children we are the
parents and it's time to say no more and
if we send a strong message with regards
to the mask
we will watch those dominoes fall thank
you thank you very much are there any
questions from the committee
not seeing any hands thank you very much
eric anthony
welcome eric thank you
this on yes yes the red light all right
uh i'm uh
assistant citizen of um auburn and uh
thank you for the opportunity to testify
i'd like to talk about the case in which
i'm involved in salem district
court
it's a mask arrest case
there have now been
four of these mask arrest cases
and the subject of the arrest was a
grandmother
who was arrested
in front of her children and her
grandchildren and the the circumstances
were that a week ahead of the
timberlane regional school district
meeting
that notice was sent out
where
it said that parents were asked to wear
or attendees were asked to wear a mask
and this was three weeks
after the governor's executive order
that rescinded the mask mandates for
public meetings and for performances
and so taking those two facts taken
together it's reasonable to
for her to assume that she had in the
words of the arrest order she had
license and privilege to enter that
meeting
she went into the meeting she actually
went to
where
people were going
in
and
then she
wanted to come back and and uh talk to
her friend who was
by this time the police had uh
who had
followed the
order of the school board the school
board put out a subsequent order that to
the police which was not public that
said that
that they were the people without mass
were to be blocked and if necessary
arrested
and so when she turned around and
she tried to motion to her friend to
come in she said i'm just going in and
then she was the policeman turned around
and arrested her
and
so i think this brings up a number of
issues
on school boards and their abuse of
authority
just on the face of it i would say it
goes to the separation of powers
these mandates are not laws they don't
behave
like laws there's not the rules of
of statutory interpretation that are
applied
to them
it gives school boards executive powers
of arrest police powers
and legislative and judicial powers to
interpret and apply these
these laws
so kate bosse was humiliated humiliated
in front of her children and
grandchildren
and was arrested under this and of
course presented from speaking she had
license and privilege
she was arrested for trespassing but
really she was arrested for not having a
mask that was and
this also forms a
classic
abuse of authority and that it's an ex
post facto uh application uh given the
two orders the uh public notice
and uh
and then later the order to the
police uh a week later
so you say a law means one thing and
then you
turn around and
and apply it a different way that's an
exposed fact application it's the rarest
of beasts in the
legal realm that you have a criminal
ex post facto
case like this
so uh that was my testimony i'd be glad
to take questions
thank you very much are there questions
from yes representative waltz
yes are you an attorney
no thank you
are there further questions from the
committee
nazi thank you very much you're welcome
kathy meal
i'm kathy mayo from nottingham thank you
and thank you for doing this
um
thank you for listening to my concerns
over the decision of masking which i
believe should be left to no one but the
parents this is my personal disclaimer
for god hath not given us the spirit of
fear but of power and of love and of a
sound mind
i've lost a lot of sleep over this and
it's been on my mind non-stop as there
is so much information and so many ways
to address this
scientifically statistically politically
socially the list goes on
the one that gnaws at me the most is
spiritually we are all spiritual beings
with souls and our children are precious
innocent and deserve to be protected not
compromised by poor decisions
especially ones that have no merit
i have yet to find one randomized
control study supporting the
effectiveness of mass they are
authorized not approved or licensed by
the federal government and
as emergency use authorization
and that's under the
federal food drug and cosmetic act and i
have the federal law title
i have a couple pictures to show you
and i do have them i can pass out
afterwards if you'd like
what is this saying about
saying about us and what message are we
giving to our children is it okay for
adults to be clumped together in a large
gathering without masks but children
have to be masked and walk single file
i'm stretched out so they don't touch
another child
do you think they don't see this
you have to be honest about the
hypocrisy and don't for a minute think
that they aren't noticing or watching
children of sponges and make
observations
more than any adult ever could it's a
huge part of how they learn and they've
been created that way for a reason and
just because the teachers wear the masks
while in school too don't you
think this causes even more confusion
for them why only in school and not
outside of school why have i seen my
teacher out of school without a mask on
i know the parents are getting these
questions all the time how do you answer
these questions
just because she has
fingers and hands as the mask over their
face
this is so disturbing
this has to break your heart this child
was asked to draw their
face and hair to make a self-portrait
just like the other picture do you see
any joy in this face
uh you won't find it of course you don't
because it's covered by a mask and not
even a pretty colored or decorated one
it's black a plain old black mask
the saying over the strong says after a
year and a half of daily mask wearing in
schools the face covering has become
part of the children's identity that's
just horrifying we're not only stripping
them of their identity dignity humanity
and self-esteem but we're robbing them
of seeing the joy of another child's
face or an adult's face correct me if
i'm wrong but i believe seeing another
person's facial expressions plays a
critical role in development
there is a day of reckoning coming
for these injustices and i can't wait
when that happens but what i'm not
looking forward to is witnessing the
damage left in its wake
we've only seen the beginnings and if we
don't stop this
a little bit of cursive
manuscript whatever you want to call it
thank you for coming
nathan flowers from jaffrey new
hampshire um
i would start by thanking you for still
holding this even though there's snow
outside so um took the trip out here um
so
i was thankful i came here and it wasn't
cancelled so thank you
um so as we've heard before little
children are sponges whether it be good
stuff or bad stuff that they hear around
them
but when they wear mass
they can't learn emotional intelligence
and communication skills go down the
drain because communication it's only 10
our voices the rest is
our faces and us moving around
so going back to the sponges thing when
um
going back to the sponge metaphor
when they're wearing a mask it's like
cutting that sponge
in half
i have four four
lovely girls at home
only two of which are in school aged
and this year when um
the school decided that they were going
to
force them to wear mass on and off um
luckily we chose to keep him home
because there's a parent's choice for
that
we were able to use the educational
freedom account to obviously fund that
which obviously again thank you guys for
pushing that through
but back to that it should be parents
choice in schools whether we want them
to wear a mask or not a personal choice
if a teacher wants to wear one or not
not forced upon by the school local
governments and so on
so that's pretty much all i wanted to
say keep it quick so more people can
talk um just a couple points i wanted to
go through
how old are your your girls so eight six
three one and then i have a fifth on the
way to may 1st wow
congratulations
all girls apparently that's all all
girls
i don't know how the genetics works in
that yeah
good luck for sure yeah have fun
thank you
it gets fun when they get up about age
22 23.
thank you then you got grandkids
are there any
is kristin here
welcome hi there
okay
i tried to edit as i went so i wasn't
repeating people um
i'm kristin jackson i'm a concord school
bus driver but i'm here representing
myself i just wanted to um give you some
insight of what i see as someone who
works with the kids so this week was um
bus driver appreciation week and i got
all these awesome cards from kids
and then i got one where they drew my
portrait and this broke my heart
so these kids
sorry every time i do this i want to
crack
i haven't seen these kids faces and i've
been driving them for two years
this is like
so safety wise this is horrible i cannot
identify the children i barely know
their names people who are standing at
the corner to pick them up
i don't know who they are i'm not
allowed to ask questions
this has been going on for so long and
it's wrecking these kids
oh my gosh
all right so i have like
you get the basics
um
i just wanted to let you know so i've
been driving a school bus for five years
um i've not seen these kids faces
i mean i drive 95 kids and if they saw
me in the street they wouldn't know who
i am this is like
thank you
i didn't think i was gonna do this
um i just want you to know like it's so
hard to build up a relationship as a
school bus driver i have about five
minutes to greet them i try my hardest
to keep everybody up and happy and then
they want us to yell at
the kids to put a mask on and cover up
their personality it's like
so against everything we do as a
volunteer to like work with children
like i don't understand at all how
anybody's making this decision unless
money is pushing them to do it even then
i mean i don't understand how people
aren't pushing back
um i work in go hogard they're still
pushing the employees to wear masks even
though we're not working with children
like in our break area it's just
ridiculous
they're just power hungry and it's like
definitely showing and people who are
here for the right reasons are being
forced out i'm definitely looking for
another job like i can't stand working
with people who are hurting children
i can't bring myself to tell kids to put
masks on
no teachers should be standing for this
i don't understand how it's been going
on for two years
um i just had a couple things that i um
i wanted to let you know how the kids
are interpreting all this stuff um
on the bus they play a little game
that's usually known as tag but they
play kobit and if you get tagged you're
it and you die this is what they think
of covid um
they wanted me last year to close the
windows because they were scared kovit
was going to come in the bus and get
them
they don't understand what's happening
and they're just being taught to fear
this is gonna mess them up for so many
years um the fear in their eyes when i
pass out the masks
um if i run out for the day because 50
kids don't have masks and i run out of
number 51 they have fear in their eyes
because they're scared i don't know if
they're scared they're going to die in
the bus but they're scared that people
are going to now go approach them and
they want to be good and they want to
behave and they want to follow the rules
and we're making them up in this awkward
position where now because they don't
have a mask on they're bad and they're
rule breakers and that's not the case
these kids are innocent and they're not
going to die from this and we're we're
putting them in a horrible position um
they're being just trained to fear and
comply and not question things when i
questioned things i was told the cops
would be called on me
at work because i didn't want to wear a
mask they were told me do it because
everybody else is nobody has answers
this is the masks we're passing out for
the children in concord
non-medical masks it says right on there
not for use for viral infections will
not stop viruses we're just doing this
this is ridiculous we're lying to their
faces and telling them believe me
because i'm an adult
i can't do that i don't understand why
my boss is telling me to do this and why
he's not questioning his boss and when i
question anybody i get in trouble this
is like this is horrible okay sorry
three minutes
don't be don't be sorry
are there any questions from the
committee representing representative
moffat
sorry thank you mr chair and uh i don't
apologize
thank you oh my god i didn't think i was
going to speak
thank you for stepping up
i'm sure we all appreciate it i asked dr
petty earlier and i hate to put you in
the spot that's okay
but i asked him about the school bus
question and if you don't know if you're
here but the
understanding is the
the uh as districts go masculine uh it
sounds like buses will be the only
places right where kids will stay
given that you're a bus driver i know
you don't make policy but you you must
have supervisors or folks who give you
uh guidance or policies so so do you
have
any sense is anything coming to you in
terms of uh
school bus mask mandates i thought i
heard march 14th was something um
federally that masks would be released
um i'm not sure though but for us we
have to when we're when we're with the
kids within
um the socially distance we have to wear
a mask all the time so there's always
kids on the bus so
i thought march 14th was something
federally happening but i'm not 100 sure
because they were going to revisit it
thank you and we can kind of follow up
on that too thank you yeah
i i have a question for you um
i i got to get this
straight
when you're driving the bus you're and i
really appreciate it we do not have
enough bus drivers in this state to have
the cdl et cetera
um
i i'm concerned that are you being asked
to ensure that these kids keep these
mass on on the bus
rather than watching the road and safety
issues around you you're now watching
kids to ensure that their mass are on
and are you having to tell them to put
the mass on while they're on the bus so
we have boxing masks that we give out
when the kids approach the bus because a
lot of them don't have masks at the bus
stops so they give them to us um i don't
know how much they're enforcing it but
i've been very cautious of not
participating in that part so if the
kids come up i hope i hold the clean
mask for them to take and if they want
it most of the kids are just they learn
from school to wear masks so if you go
to pick up run at school 100 of the kids
walk on the bus with a mask and they
don't question it so i get that part
yeah my question is when they're on the
bus and let's say a youngster takes a
mask off
are you required a lot of bus drivers
definitely do reprimands you are told to
tell them to get the mass back on
i don't they're not then we're not
penalized if we don't so i just went
with that as my my i offer the masks and
then it's up to them but we're supposed
to still pick up kids if they don't have
masks and they won't wear them and then
the school deals with them at their
level
we're more focused on the road
yeah i hope so
represent hobson
thank you mr chair and thank you for
being here your testimony was very
powerful
i had not uh thought of the burden that
that puts on you
as a bus driver to make sure
that
the right person is picking up a child
off of the bus
do you believe it's a matter of time
before something
really scary happens i mean we've
definitely had children not being able
to be identified that were on the buses
so even that kids getting on the wrong
bus at the beginning of the year was
all the time i mean now it's been more
steady but if kids wanted to go on a
different bus we can only identify them
from two inches on their face
so it's just it's just gonna happen for
sure yeah
further questions from the committee
not seeing any hands thank you very much
thank you so much for your time stay
with it please thank you
andrew minus
good morning members of the committee
thank you for allowing me to speak
i'm andrew minus i live in derry new
hampshire a homeowner there since 2007.
today i am also representing rebuild new
hampshire i'm the chairman and founder
of that organization
and i am presenting uh to the committee
a petition with 5161
5161 names on it
um so those people are behind me in this
room right now
and they all believe the same things
that you've heard today from all of
these people so i want to say i
apologize for being late uh i the snow
kind of delayed me
but other people made it here on time
and i'm thankful for that
i want to say that i came in during
stephen petty's testimony
and
for the record i agree and submit to you
the same comments as every single person
from that point till now
i agree with everything i heard so far
um and and and that's why i'm here
before you today my three children thank
god
um go to a private school two different
private schools
and i fought
very hard with those private schools to
prevent masking from becoming a
requirement there so to date praise god
my children have not worn a mask one
time
not in public not anywhere they've never
worn one and i am so grateful for that
um i want and i'm doing this i i started
the organization because i want other
people's children to have that same
right
it's not a privilege it's a right to be
able to breathe god's clean air that he
made for us
and as a matter of fact
the rest of my testimony i'll read the
last line of this because that's the
part that's that's relevant therefore we
the undersigned hereby ask that the
house pass legislation to ban facial
covering mandates for students in all
public schools in new hampshire
and that's what i'm here for that's what
you know both of these bills we support
we support any effort whatsoever to
prevent local school districts
from
requiring masks on on children for all
the reasons you heard today
and we also i i would submit to you
personally that i do not believe in
local control
new hampshire is not a home rule state
we have a state legislature that is very
representative of people of the whole
state and we have uniform laws
throughout the whole state so you don't
have to go from one town to another and
check the law books
we should be able to go from one town to
another and know what the law is because
the state has put it in place and the
government's role is in fact to protect
the people's individual liberty that is
the number one reason why we have
government at all individual liberty
protection that's your job
and i did it once so i appreciate it
um
now
i i guess
to that point i would say that the
governor has has made a announcement
that you know many people might say well
now we don't need this
um and i would submit to you that the
opposite is in fact true um we we very
much need to pass this legislation to
prevent
in the future these local
uh government authorities
that don't have the authority from
putting in place these these types of
mass mandates on our children
we have the right to breathe oxygen we
have the right to show the image of god
that he made for us to each other
and i would submit to you that a mask
um
is an occult symbol
and and and we're what we're facing
right here is literally a religious
spiritual battle between
the forces of darkness and the forces of
light god made us in his image this is
his image you all have his image on you
and i pray to you
that you allow our children to show
god's image thank you thank you very
much andrew are there any questions from
the committee
yes
are you suggesting anybody that wears a
mask is a force of evil
i think that's a ridiculous statement
and i'm not going to answer it
i'm just trying to follow through on
what you said that mask said i didn't
say what you said
i'm asking that's to me the logical next
step i'm asking if that's what you
believe because it's not the logical
next step it's an absolutely ludicrous
thing to say
okay let's let's move on here okay thank
you very much are there any other
questions from the committee
thank you
um oh so i'd like one of these to go
with the permanent record of
1371 and the other can go to 1131.
okay melissa you got me with your name
wherever you are economic uh
economicus okay there you go thank you
conor marcus
thank you for seeing me thank you for
doing this we appreciate it
i spent hours and hours and hours of
research
um
and i'd like to present it to you too
you know i might like just give it to
you i highlighted everything so you
don't have to read through all the
documents just read through the
highlighted things to make it easier
um
hi my name is melissa konomakas and i'm
in support of hp 1131 to prohibit
schools whether public or private from
creating policies that force students or
members of the public to wear mass
some people may believe in the train
theory and some may believe in the germ
theory i will speak on the premises that
viruses are what are what makes people
sick and present to you
that mass do more harm than good and
that they don't work
first of all when people speak sing or
laugh they they eject saliva from their
mouth which i know you might be all
thinking well all the more reason to
wear masks right
um but i'll get to that the argument
later
according to dr
robert palmer an
nih expert on oral microbes in our mouth
we have about 700 species
of microbes
including germs like bacteria fungus and
more exhaled droplets become trapped in
the masks
and the damp masks cause the bacteria to
proliferate which turns
which in turn is being inhaled into the
lungs
whereas without a mask exhale drop
droplets in aerosols are known to dry
quickly
i have with me documented studies of
contaminations having been found on the
inside of mass
staff
staphylococcus
streptococcus and bacillus to just name
a few please see the articles in here
dangers of pathogens on found on
children's face masks
cotton and surgical face masks in
community settings bacterial
contamination in the face max mask
hygiene
mask fall security and real dangers
microbial challenges from mass and
medical doctor warns that bacterial
pneumonias
are on the rise from mask wearing
second
many masks are made of polyester which
contain microplastics
and even the small portion of
synthetic fibers break off from the mask
then they are possibly if not
of not
only entry into the foreign material
into the airways
but also entry into the deep lung tissue
causing potential pathological
consequences due to the foreign bodies
in our lungs please see article
dangers of mass
third
people
[Music]
people are inhibiting their oxygen
intake which lowers their oxygen levels
in their blood
and rebreathing in their co2 which
raises co2 levels in their blood causing
their bodies to become more acidic
please see the articles mass are harmful
i won't read all the articles because of
any time but
i wrote them in there moreover
scientists have found toxic chemicals in
the face mask such as formaldehyde and
cobalt which gives it the pretty blue
color
there are over 70 000 new companies now
registered to manufacture and sell mass
in china and according to the general
product safety regulations as mass
covering face coverings are not medical
devices and they do not regulate these
products
there have been numerous studies that
have been performed by doctors and
scientists which show mass are
ineffective
and i'm not even going to go into the
poor sizes or anything like that
um
unless you've gone beyond your time so
you're gonna have to wrap it up here
please okay
um anyway there's lots of studies in
here that show that
mass don't work
um
when we when we speak
the mass gets moisture on there
and um
the damp mass causes less air
permeability so it will limit how much
viral particles is able to hold and it
said it's only 20 minutes before the
mass
become damp
um and back in march 2020
epidemiologists and inspectors disease
experts were at the pains to emphasize
against the unwarranted scramble for
masks
so back then they were saying um the
surgeon general jerome adams said
seriously people stop buying mass unless
you're going to have to try and wrap
that up quickly here okay we have more
people who want to speak here okay i'm
sorry well you can um
be the rest of it then i guess we'll we
will look at all this stuff i really
appreciate you looking at it because i
spent hours
doing this
any questions why we're here to hear
from you and then look at the
information that's provided to us so we
thank you are there
are there any questions from the
committee
not seeing any thank you very much
if you could bring that over to julius
or or to oliver and they will make sure
it gets up here and it will be
submitted thank you
uh alexandra
uh
manila
this is alexander
alex yeah you can call me alex that's
fine
um so thank you for giving me the time
to talk to you all about masks and you
know i think we're all tired of it i
know i'm pretty tired of it but like
there's still people willing to come out
in a blizzard
to discuss this and kind of fight back
on it so it's pretty serious and
it's not going to get resolved because
you have two groups of people who
completely disagree with each other
right and
forcing one group to bend to the other
group's will is not the solution right
so when you pass laws and the school
board passes mandates and
the cdc says one thing right it's it's
not going to work out the the best way
to solve the only way to solve this
is to realize that
our rights
belong to the individual right we have a
right to make
choices for our children and for
ourselves for our own help going to
something else here uh i have experience
as a former environmental health and
safety specialist
for a utility company in new york city i
worked there for 12 years and i'm still
in that same industry so i have 14 years
total
experience working with osha regulations
one of my roles in the past was
selecting personal protective equipment
for industrial work which included the
use of respirators
respirators are used to protect against
airborne contaminants
obviously today there's been an official
claim that there are tiny airborne virus
particles floating all around the earth
threatening the life on planet earth
right and this claim is made without any
evidence whatsoever now you're going to
point to positive pcr tests
hospitalizations deaths i understand
that but none of these things are
evidence of contaminated air or the need
for the use of a respirator 24 7.
has anyone seen an air sample for sars
cove too
if we took an air sample in this room
right now would would someone be able to
show me the presence of sars cove 2 and
tell me that my life was in jeopardy
um or are we just comfortable going off
of wmur's case counter
that's what we've been doing
anyway before employing a respirator
the first step would be to prove the
existence of a hazardous atmosphere so
that we could know which type of
respirator would be appropriate to use
now our atmosphere is hazardous but it's
not for coronavirus it's because of poor
environmental practices in favor of
profit uh dumping fluoride into our
water supply and we're also marinating
in cell tower radiation but nobody wants
to talk about that so
that's just like god intended it that
stuff aside the first step is perv it
which no one has done
after we proved it we would need to
select an appropriate respirator the
purpose of a paper medical mask is to
prevent bacteria from contaminating
medically sterile environments
these masks do not protect you from
supposed viruses floating in the air
because they do not provide an airtight
seal
they're an illusion of safety
i'll continue and then
just think of this before 2020 when you
went to visit your doctor for cold or
flu did any of you wear a mask in front
of your doctor did your doctor wear a
mask
why is that
because that's not how this works that's
not how your immune system works
we have an immune system i'll finish up
quickly we have an immune system that
generally functions very well and
sustains many years of life i think the
average life expectancy in america is
like high 70s here so it's pretty good
just on natural immunity
nothing changed in 2020 except our
perception of alleged viruses in our
health thanks to the hysterical media
and hysterical leadership
and then last thing once we select an
appropriate respirator that can provide
an airtight seal by osha's standard 29
cfr 1910 which i've brought with me and
i'll share with you all a doctor needs
to evaluate the person donning a
respirator to make sure they're
medically fit to put something over
their face that inhibits breathing
once they're cleared again according to
osha a respirator fit test must be
performed to test the seal and you have
to do a positive and negative pressure
test we don't do that in schools
children are not doing this so osha
standards went out the window along with
common sense and years of common medical
knowledge government solution has just
been to do something just do something
to create a show of doing something uh
even if it's not effective or only
creates an illusion of safety uh we're
done with that the the jig is up here
this can never be allowed to happen
again so
i support this bill and the next one
and we just we demand that you guys just
step out of the way and let us manage
our own health and health of our our
children
you guys have no authority the school
boards have no authority to dictate what
medical treatment
um we we do for our children and that it
doesn't matter what beth daley says or
what ben chan says or the cdc belongs to
us
and i want to thank you for your time
thank you very much alex kind of hoping
that the average lifespan was in the 80s
yeah i'll take 78. it rounds up
that gives me a couple years
so thank you very much are there any uh
questions from the committee
not seeing ants thank you okay thank you
and thank you for battling against
mother nature out there
okay going on kelly potenza
so three minutes um that's a little hard
and i
could talk for this for on hours but i'm
actually i wasn't going to speak on this
personally but i am
my kids have always been in in private
school
except for
the year that the school year that cobot
hit
and
we saw a lot of things and um
school shut down
and then we were like wow that was a
mistake
it was a mistake from a lot of things
that we saw
in the public schools and
um
and so we basically decided okay well
we're gonna we're you know come
september
school's gonna be open we're gonna go
back to a private school that we were at
and so
the grass wasn't greener there
my daughter my oldest daughter
has had in
a diagnosed anxiety
diagnosis since she was three
she can't wear a mask
so
this is when my
whole process started so she was a
patient at dartmouth-hitchcock
and there is no
pediatrician
that there's no one in the state that
would give a medical exemption
for my child they had been treating her
for 10 years they knew everything about
her
they knew she had some adhd stuff as but
her main thing was her anxiety
and they just ignored that and so when i
demanded
an exemption from her
they basically said
they gave me a letter that said well
we'll train her
how to wear a mask
everything with this whole thing is just
disgusting there's no such thing as
as disabilities anymore there's no such
thing as as any of it
this was carmella's at the time
um my daughter her
her therapist
so they said go go to her therapist to
get an exemption you can't get one from
a therapist in this date as well
number one so i said i just want to
document all the following issues
before the appointment today
carmel has diagnosed anxiety and adhd
she's got an iep
carmella's blood pressure becomes highly
elevated immediately when she puts on a
mask wearing a mask is detrimental to
her mental health and well-being
my daughters had two doctor appointments
where her blood pressure was not able to
be taken because it was too high to
measure
the minute she put on a mask it went off
the charts
they actually had to take the mask off
for her to get even an elevated blood
pressure reading
so i told this all to the therapist
my daughter says i sweat like a pig when
i wear a mask i am so hot i feel
suffocated i find it these are all
quotes i find it hard to breathe with a
mask on
her mask makes her feel uncomfortable
and nervous
my daughter has great anxiety
around wearing a mask
my daughter is thrown up in the car on
the way to school multiple times because
of her anxiety about having to wear a
mask it's cool
i have a hard time learning why i'm
wearing a mask because it bothers me a
lot
she feels the mask is very distracting
my daughter was in school four days of
school
and she said i hate school
and the mask was impeding her learning
my daughter's physical health is also
being greatly impacted because of the
anxiety surrounding wearing a mask at
school
my daughter lost 20 freaking pounds
from august
all the way up till december
and dartmouth hitchcock did nothing
this therapist said for her to come in
for her deployment she had to wear a
mask
if you don't know what's wrong here i
had to pull her out of school wonderful
best private school in the state
the governor's kids go to that school
isn't that interesting
literally november first had to pull her
out we homeschooled
now they're at another private school
and it's working out but
i just i'll speak on the next one
because there's i know there's not
enough time but
this is what we're in i don't think you
realize how many people have been
fighting for a long time on this and
it's absolutely appalling that we are
still here
appalling thank you you don't have the
right you don't have the authority
thank you are there any questions
thank you very much
lynn larue
hi there
hello hi thanks for letting me speak my
name is lynn leroux i live in nashua new
hampshire i have a 15 year old and an
almost 17 year old at nashua south
i'm a registered nurse i work in the
emergency department and the icu at one
of the city's hospitals
i have been working in covid in the
emergency department since it started
and i'll tell you what i saw
a four to six time
rate of kids being admitted for suicide
ideation severe anxiety depression this
was not only from not being in school
but for my own child this was the
anxiety from having to wear a mask
i'm a nurse i recognize signs and
symptoms in mental health any nurse will
tell you half of nursing is
mental health problems
even even when you're dealing with
medical issues
the root of it is usually
usually
a mental health issue
my own daughter tried to take her own
life last year i didn't recognize it
like i should have
i'm i'm trained to recognize these signs
and symptoms right it wasn't only not
being in school she was she had anxiety
from wearing a mask similar to kelly's
daughter
we were on vacation we returned she
tried to take her own life had to admit
her into an inpatient facility
she did some outpatient treatment after
that for months
and the
the ultimate diagnosis was severe
anxiety as a result of being forced to
wear a mask
when i worked in the emergency
department i took care of these kids
these kids were not sick with covid
these kids were not sick with any other
medical issue these sick these kids were
sick with mental health problems and as
we all know mental problems mental
health problems aren't fixed easily
right it's not it's not like taking
medication for a heart attack it's not
like taking
quitting smoking to reduce your chances
of lung cancer mental health problems
are forever she will battle this forever
similar
to what some other parents have said
my school district was the last to
return to school they only returned to
public school after the governor
mandated it
and my daughter wanted to go back to
school she wanted to be with her friends
she had a choice the choice was to wear
a mask or not go to school
or go to school wear a mask and get on
medication and this is what my daughter
chose to do she's on medications that
she does not need so that she can
tolerate the mask
i've been in the icu for a year now i
started last year when a couple of
nurses had coveted and they were out
they needed
more nurses so i moved to the icu i've
been there for a year i still work in
the emergency department on a peridium
basis i'm working there tonight
um
so i know who gets
sick from covid it's multiple
comorbidities age is a huge risk factor
kids are not at risk for catching
and they're not the primary transmitters
of kovid
you are harming the least at-risk group
of individuals with these mask mandates
i'm here in support of this bill i hope
that you will consider passing it thank
you thank you are there any questions
from the committee not seeing any thank
you very much for coming today thank you
you're welcome linda blake
hi thank you welcome um i'm just here as
somebody who works in the school i've
been working with kids for about 40
years
and i see firsthand what's happening to
the kids in the schools i work with some
kids with disabilities
i see
anxiety i see fear
i see sadness depression in my own
family i also had a suicide attempt
a grandson with severe anxiety
another granddaughter with anxiety
and myself i'm really really easy going
person i've never had so much anxiety in
my life working in the school
i
told the
administration that i could not tell
kids to wear a mask because it is
it is child abuse
and
i was told to think about another job
which i have absolutely thought about
and thought about and thought about i
will not tell a child to put a mask on
their face i still don't
but i see it every day
i don't want to leave the kids
because that has been my life
and i just see what it's doing to them
and it is disgusting
an absolute child abuse
and that's really all i want to say
please pass this bill
thank you
are there any questions from the
committee
thank you very much
i got this last card here and
roseanne you've already spoken
if if a person wants to come up and you
can sit by her that's
committee fine are not even paying
attention they're reading and eating and
and it's not okay
it's not okay that someone is so afraid
to speak because of the because of the
way the people are being intimidated
that's not okay she wants to speak it'll
be less than three minutes
she's welcome
amanda why don't you come on up and
speak
are you okay
welcome amanda
thank you
so this is something that i wrote
and it says before you judge someone for
not wearing a mask i ask that you think
about a few things
imagine that the person resistant to
wearing a mask has been held down in a
forceful way with a hand over their
mouth and nose blocking them from
screaming for help and gasping for air
imagine the fear that still lives within
these people
who have survived situations where their
voice was minimized and they couldn't
breathe
when you put on your mask
are your first thoughts i wonder when
the feeling of gasping for air is going
to begin this time will it take five
minutes or will it take one minute
when will the panic set in i wonder when
i speak if anyone will hear me
imagine the feeling of their bodies
shutting down
as they remember the look
in their abusers eyes the flashbacks the
sounds the panic and don't forget
looking around for someone to save them
this is what's happening when trying to
get groceries for their family these
reminders and this panic
let's remember we have no idea what
anyone around us has been through we can
only control ourselves and our own
bodies you are free to make your own
choice and if you have to judge someone
else for theirs judge lightly it's heavy
enough out there
very good thanks well done amanda
well done
you're welcome you're welcome
we did linda right
yes
i don't have any other cards on this
bill so we're going to close this
hearing now
and we're going to take a a five minute
break here some of us have to stretch a
little bit and pe teachers tell us
stretch and
exercise a little bit
because my son wasn't like
every other child in that school
and as i
as i
um
went through this process i realized
that all children
are very unique and all children are
very individual
um
and so
covet hit us
and the mass mandates came out and they
wanted basks and you know
stores and
mass and everywhere
and my son hated it
he's still at my house and he hated it
we spent years teaching him how to read
facial expressions
so he could understand
the intent of people
and so he hated masks
and i heard a lot about that
but what was worse is i i saw other
children that hated them i saw other
adults that hated them
and i saw a split in our society
between masked and unmasked
and i saw the behavior
that each of us have toward each other
due to this split due to this mask
and what really pushed me on this bill
was when i saw
adults
yelling at children
and telling the children
that they didn't care about their
friends
if they weren't wearing a mask that they
wanted to kill their friends if they're
wearing a mask
and i was like wait what are we doing
what are we doing as people
is this the society we want
is what we're gaining
worth it
now this last bill that we just heard
you heard a lot of the
pluses or minuses of mass and the
arguments are out there for both sides
but i'm not going to do that today i'm
not going to sit here and try to make
that argument with you i'm going to make
an argument for a couple of things
and they're the things this bill is
hoping to address
um
and there may be some work i need to do
on it still
the first thing is who's the best person
to make a decision
about a mask choice for the child
is it the governor
does he know my child the best
is it
the legislature
is it the school boards
elected folks that we put on our school
boards
do they know my child the best
is it the school
or is it the parent themselves
i can tell you
that i had a great iep team i had great
people working with me with my son
but i can tell you for a fact not one of
them knows my son as well as i do
not a single one
so
as we look at things
we tend to say we need a solution and we
need a fast solution and in doing that
we say let's have a broad brush solution
because it's the easiest and fastest to
employ
one size fits all
unfortunately with kids one size does
not fit all
so
i wrote this bill to say hey
i think it's best
unless you can show some really
significant value
in a blanket solution i think it's best
if the parent that understands that
child the best and that child's
individual needs individual physiology
works with the doctors looks at the
evidence they certainly have the passion
to i mean
look at the people we have here today
that came through a snow storm to talk
to you about it so they've got the
passion
to do all that work do school boards
have that passion were their school
board members
shuffling through things trying to
figure out each individual child i don't
think so
so i think
the best bet is to let the parents do it
and then
the other thing i wanted this bill to
address
is
how we treat people after they've made
that decision
so we have some folks that decide to
wear masks today and some folks that
don't
should we all be treating each other the
same
should i treat these folks badly because
they don't have a mask or these folks
badly because they do
i don't believe we should
and so i sought with this to say hey we
need to treat
harassment
shaming
okay
on masks
we need to treat that with the same zero
tolerance policy we treat bullying with
we already have metrics in our school
systems for
you know
um
how to deal with with folks that bully
okay why not apply those same metrics
to
folks that
harass or
shame people on their mass choice
regardless of what that choice is i i
really don't care
um and so that's what i'm seeking to do
with this bill
they wanted to make sure
that
the schools weren't responsible for
tracking everybody's masking choice if
the parents are going to make the choice
it that makes a lot of sense
but how does a school
know which child is supposed to be
wearing a mask and which one isn't and
so i want to make sure that it's in
writing that the schools aren't
responsible for that
that the parent makes the choice
and the parent talks to the child and
makes sure that sure that the child is
doing what the parent wishes
that the schools don't even have to
think about whether that child needs a
master that one doesn't
that's between the parent and the child
and
it's not the school bus drivers
as i saw in the previous testament it's
not the school bus driver's
responsibility to make sure
let's see john's supposed to be but uh
bobby's not
okay this is on this
um
so if there's other issues that you guys
see that you want to have addressed i'll
be glad to hear from you and see what i
can do to to get that done
um
and other than that i
i really do
wish again to thank all the people that
showed up this was a tremendous i mean
that's a tremendous effort in a storm
like the one we're having right now
so
thank you very much and i'll take
questions thank you very much
representative are there questions from
the committee
not seeing any hands thank you very much
thank you
bob dabrowski
thank you i'm bob dybrowski i'm from
candia new hampshire
um i'm going to start right at the top
and give you my biggest point first and
i'm going to make this real fast so
don't worry and then talk about
a little bit of the detail
if you care
rsa 358
is a very important law in new hampshire
it
it is the consumer protection laws it is
illegal in new hampshire to sell
for use for virus protection fake mass
if the mass doesn't have a filter in it
you cannot sell it for virus protection
you cannot label it under rsa 358 you
can't package it you cannot advertise it
you cannot post it on the internet for
that use you can't put it on a display
rack in your store it's illegal
what we have here is a very peculiar
situation where school boards are saying
well hey we're not selling the mass
we're just forcing the kids to wear the
mask that doesn't work and doesn't have
a filter in it
there's nothing wrong with that we never
sold it
no no that
that's untenable
the notion that you're not selling the
mask
therefore you have the right to force
someone to wear that same fake mask that
is outrageous
this bill is so easy it's so simple i
don't know how it i mean this ought to
pass
i you know 100 percent vote
all this bill does
is it stops somebody primarily from
wearing fake masks almost all children
in new hampshire wear fake masks with no
filters in them i have some at my chair
i can show them to you if you wish you
can cut them open shake them there's
nothing in there
they're empty
nobody here almost everybody here i'm
going to guess drove here in a car
nobody brings their car to the auto
dealer and says hey unscrew the filter
canister for me but don't put a can
don't put a filter in there i just want
i just want an oil change without that
filter just charge me for it but don't
put the filter nobody would do that you
get an actual filter element when you
get your oil change in your car
but the children are wearing fake masks
with no filters in them
and then the people say geez i wonder
why they don't work well that's why they
don't work
they're not supposed to work
it even says
you know people
people got all hung up on studies today
and fine studies i believe in studies
but you don't even have to bother with
studies you can just go right on the cdc
website it's right here i just printed
it off this morning
it says right here
does not provide protection for airborne
particles not considered respiratory
protection what are the kids wearing the
surgical mask that doesn't provide
protection
it's outrageous to me
if you want a site to study you want to
play that game sure go on to a different
cdc page right here
was not statistically significant for
cloth mass oops they did the study come
to find out
there was more negative
excuse me more positive tests for the
cloth mass wearers
more people got sick wearing the fake
mess
this is on the cdc website you can just
ignore all of the all of the fog of well
this study and this this country and
china and everything no
you just go right to the city said what
cdc website says right there in fact
the prevalence of fake mass is so severe
that they also have that on the cdc
website you can't make this up
counterfeit respirators
it is so prevalent they actually have a
special page and you could just get the
down button page and just page and page
and page and they show hundreds of masks
that are faked it's unbelievable
it's unbelievable
so getting back to mass uh in 95.
i'm i'm going to be real fast so
children children can't wear an n95
there are no n95s in the united states
for children and iosh won't certify them
kids do not work around asbestos lead
that's when n95s are primarily made for
so you can't even get an n95 certified
mask for a child they don't exist so
again i'd like you to look at rsa
358 and look at this in the context of
it's illegal to sell these mass in new
hampshire to label market etc for virus
protection how could you a school board
even dare
to force a kid to wear that mask that's
illegal to be sold for that purpose
thank you thank you
any questions from the committee
thank you
andrew minus
thank you committee members andrew
menews dairy new hampshire chairman of
rebuild new hampshire
support the bill and submitted petitions
for it earlier
i just wanted to add to what i mentioned
earlier
my children
during the height of the pandemic i
brought them out to the supermarket
because i wanted them to see the world
and experience other people besides
their mom and dad and brothers and
sisters
um
you know it proved to be a teachable
moment to be sure we had a gentleman
probably in his 40s to 60s come up to us
and start screaming at our faces and at
my children
um you know telling them that their
father was setting a bad example for
them um you know and uh
and then he looked to me and said
is this what you want to teach your
children and and i looked at them and i
i said very calmly sir
yes it is what i want to teach them i
want to teach them to stand up to
bullies i want to stand i want to teach
them to do the right thing no matter
what pressure is coming up against them
to do the wrong thing and i think that
this is probably one of the best lessons
they've had all year
and i said i'm gonna i'm gonna turn and
get to my grocery shopping now
this is my cell phone number if you'd
like to sit down and have a coffee with
me we could talk about this some more
um i never heard from the guy
but
the point of the matter is that
that was one of many
circumstances that one involving my
children and it was a wonderful lesson
that they learned i want other children
to have that same ability i think this
is a great bill
nobody should be told that they're going
to kill other people because they're not
wearing a mask that's and and
unfortunately that is not only
what our government was saying and you
know
fauci being the chief among them saying
lies like that
uh but um you know our teachers were
telling that to to public school
children in the school room and
it's just unconscionable i don't know
how you can go and look at yourself in
the mirror
uh at the end of the day and feel okay
with yourself after saying something
like that a lie like that to a child
um and and so to that point i began
bringing a mirror around with me and
putting it in my pocket when i went to
the grocery store i did not have the
opportunity to use it but my intent was
if anyone started screaming at me again
i was just going to hold up the mirror
and let them know that what they were
doing
is not what they should be doing look at
yourself look at what you're doing to
other people do you want that on your
conscience
sad that we have to have a bill to ask
that question but
i think we do thank you very much thank
you very much are there any questions
from the committee
now thank you very much
okay the next individual is
kelly potenza
so i'm going to actually continue on
with my previous testimony
so this is what i sent the
this is what i had sent the
psychiatrist that met with my daughter
mrs so-and-so spent spending 18 minutes
with carmela then coming to the
conclusion that she can wear a mask
quote unquote no problem is
irresponsible and disturbing
what kind of mental health center
are you
are you all that spending 18 minutes
after not seeing her for six months
because they shut it down
is enough to make that determination
after all of the information i have
provided to you it is most definitely it
most definitely feels
like a place where providers are not
putting the interests of their patients
first
that is for sure
you can guarantee
that the counseling center of new
england will be held fully responsible
and liable if my daughter has a panic
attack anxiety attack or any other
mental health breakdown at school or
anywhere else because she is required to
wear a mask for an extended period of
time when she has long standing
diagnosed disabilities these kinds of
occurrences can cause significant and
lasting mental and physical harm
i would like to tell you uh two
scenarios that happened at the school
which caused me to pull my kids out
mind you this is a private school
the the thing that was most debilitating
for my daughter was because it was
covering her entire face she felt like
she couldn't breathe
so she always would if it was just
underneath her nose you know she was
okay
so there was a science teacher
that used to this is the speaks into
this bill about the bullying and the
sensor shaming and said you know keep my
mother alive she used to say that to the
kids all the time
another teacher
um
after the third time this happened i
basically said that i would sue the
school so they were kind of like
politely asked to leave but in any case
would go over and
physically touch my kid's face and pull
the mask over her nose because she's not
wearing it correctly
this is the kind of stuff that has taken
place
rampantly throughout the state
and i would like to of course i've
signed that petition
with rebuild reopen new hampshire as
well i want to make sure that that
petition not only is on record i want it
on the calendar i want that to be
infused in this house
there are
there are redress of grievances there
are um rules that should be followed
with that i want that petition to be
known not just in this committee i want
that to be fully through the house and i
know that how that works and petitions
need to be heard thoroughly
i'd also like to just
say the same thing about new hampshire
the state of new hampshire is not a home
rule state the constitution delegates
that only the general court may suspend
laws of the state
part 1 article 29 i know my time is up
and the power to make laws that
authority only lies
with
of course the legislature the school
boards never had any authority at all
and we've been literally hijacked and
held hostage
because what it takes is lawyers that
are not stepping up in this state and
public officials that are not doing
anything either to include
our head of state
so
we can never let this happen again i
would really like this bill to be
to be pushed through quickly i mean i
know how it normally works
if this is i want this expedited we
should be talking to the governor we
should you know he came out on wednesday
if this is what they really want the doe
you get the governor behind it we need
full force here we can't wait until june
and i just want to make that clear if
this passes through it should be parent
choice that's pretty much it it really
needs to this has got to get done
because
words don't speak anymore anymore so
uh i'd like to invite rachel goldsmith
not here
okay maureen hardy
hello again
i'm maureen hardy from londonderry
i would like my testimony from the
previous bill to also apply to this bill
and i will be providing that
electronically so that you can click on
the links
the previous bill was hb1131 and this
one is
hb1371
i wanted to touch briefly on
the bangladesh study
that was mentioned previously that is
supposedly a study in favor of masking
and i wanted to point out
that even if that was a legitimate study
it found no
benefit from wearing cloth masks at all
and it only found an 11 benefit from
wearing a surgical mask and that was
only in the age 50 plus
cohort so it has absolutely no relevance
to school children
i also want to read
something very quickly this is from
new england journal of medicine from
early in the pandemic and it's from five
positions writing to the journal
and this is from the article
it is also clear that masks serve
symbolic roles
masks are not only tools they are also
talismans that may help increase
healthcare workers perceived sense of
safety well-being and trust in their
hospitals although such reactions may
not be strictly logical we are all
subject to fear and anxiety especially
during time of crisis one might argue
that fear and anxiety are better
countered with data and education than
with a marginally beneficial mask
particularly in light of the worldwide
mass shortage but is it difficult to get
clinicians to hear this message in the
heat of the current crisis
expanding masking protocol's greatest
contribution
may be to reduce the transmission of
anxiety
over and above
whatever role they may play in reducing
transmission of coven 19. so i just want
to point out that this is why it should
be parents choice
people who do not have this anxiety
should not
have to make their children wear masks
and if people do have the anxiety they
should be totally free to wear masks um
finally i just want to
share a small story of what i've
observed
i i started attending school
board meetings in the fall because of my
concern for the children
and i observed a parent uh speaking to
the school board about the bullying that
her child was receiving because she
chose not to wear a mask but the time
masks were optional in londonderry
and she had screenshots of the horrible
comments that were sent to her child
and she had all this evidence and she
was showing it to the school board
and she was told to just stop flat at
three minutes she wasn't allowed to
finish her testimony
and she said i just want to ask one
question
and the school board chairman told her
we don't answer questions
so
i really think a bill like this is
important so that the school boards
listen to parents if their child is
being bullied and also to make it clear
that being bullied for not wearing a
mask
is just as bad as any other kind of
bullying and that's all i have to say
thank you very much are there questions
from the committee
you can ask
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question did you say earlier
that you were a nurse
no i was a clinical microbiologist
thank you very much
would it be okay if i were to follow up
with you sure
if you have a question yeah thank you
okay
um
i'm gonna preface this with a would you
believe
that i have an 11 year old and at open
circle
recently
they went around the room with a what
annoys you
and one child spoke up and they said it
annoys them when not everybody gets the
vaccine
and when they got to the teacher the
teacher spoke up
and said that they are annoyed when not
everyone wears their mask properly
i want you to understand that my
children have been through a lot even
though i did get the shot and i did
still get covered but they assumed
because i sit here without a mask or
you know whatever i'm republican i
didn't get vaccinated um
that being said i have questions for you
about this bill and i want to ask any
experts out there because i worry about
unintended consequences okay so my
questions are
number one
number one i fear that we've broken the
ice out there with a mass okay so i'm
afraid it could become a crutch i've
heard superintendents actually say maybe
we can eradicate cold and flu season
right by in the schools by having mass
all the time but my question is
and i'm i'm not a scientist okay my
degree is in accounting um i'm assuming
we have a pandemic once every hundred
years but
but what happens if if we pass a bill
like this and at some point we really do
need them so
that's part a of my question
and i'm going to give you a part b
if that's okay secondly
my fear also is when it comes to these
particular bills
you know i know we're arguing that these
masks are ineffective
i don't necessarily disagree i just
worry that if we push too hard on it is
it suddenly going to become that our
children have to wear three-ply masks
with filters or suddenly the n95 is okay
for the child
so i was just curious in your expert
opinion if you had comments on either of
those two points
um
my comment on a is you're worried if a
more dangerous virus comes around i'm
assuming a respiratory virus
um the masks will still be
useless against that virus and if
anything would give a false sense of
security
um
to
the public that they are protecting
themselves by wearing masks out in
public and they should probably take
other precautions
part b is about more stringent masking
there could be a disease that goes
around that may need
a respirator that would need to be fit
tested
but
these respirators are not approved for
they're not approved for children
they're not for children to wear they're
not sized for children they're
uncomfortable to wear i know when i wore
one i could only wear it for maybe 45
minutes or an hour and i had to stop
leave the hood leave the room and and
catch some breath before i can go back
to work so i don't really think it's
plausible
for some kind of a
universal mandatory
mask or respirator policy to be put
forth anywhere
thank you are there any other questions
from the committee
not seeing any any hands thank you
yeah why don't you come on up now then
excuse my uh state of undress
um my name is rachel goldsmith i'm a
manchester resident of seven years
and chair of moms for liberty
hillsborough county
we heard earlier that
there has been no randomized controlled
study
done on children for
masking
and i looked into why that is uh it's
considered unethical by scientists to
perform a study
um with controls and variables on
experimental devices in a potentially
life-threatening situation so
the reason that we've never done a study
on children or even on adults is because
it's literally unethical by scientists
and doctors and yet representatives of
our government
believe that they are confident enough
to make medical decisions for granite
state families and individuals
if masks worked we'd see significant
differences in ifrs between 23 months
old and 24 months old
we don't
we'd see mass deaths in states without
masks compared to states with mandates
and we don't
public health officials have called
cloth masks no more than facial
decorations
i find those words extremely offensive
they are not facial decorations they are
impediments to socialization
verbal and non-verbal communication and
emotional development
they are the direct cause of 150
increase in suicide and teen girls
uh doubling uh
excuse me
doubled numbers of toddlers with speech
delays
speech delays
in fact the cdc just released an update
to toddler milestones for the first time
in 20 years decreasing the number of
words considered normal at 2 from 200
words
to 100.
this is not because children are somehow
less capable of speaking
for a reason other than
the
language development challenges
associated with not being able to see
the faces of their parents of their
adults in their lives and of their peers
i know that it's hard to change your
mind when you've been convinced of
something
for a long time
but the science has changed
we hear that from everyone
if that's true
then why are public schools using
metrics to determine mitigation
strategies
that were determined two years ago
instead of today
schools are losing students at
unprecedented rates
they need to change something or they're
going to have to make alterations to
their budgets
look around today
face friendly activists are filling the
room
where are the people that you claim to
represent
this is not for you
who are forcing children to cover their
faces
new hampshire can be a leader in the
country for freedom
the whole nation is watching us we have
an opportunity here
school boards are taking their lead from
you and from
state officials
please support this bill and set the
tone of science and rationality thank
you thank you
other questions from the committee
not seeing you thank you very much
kristen jackson
kristin
okay i just wanted to say that i have
definitely seen kids being bullied um
for not wearing a mask the kids even go
after adults if they see them without
wearing masks um it's what they've been
told for years so this is definitely as
crazy as the town it's very important to
implement
i also wanted to just say
if you think of the masked timeline if
parents are choosing to send their kids
to school with a mask um
they get out of their car and they're
using an old mask a dirty mask the bus
drivers we try our best people we can't
wash our hands before we hand out the
masks we've been driving all day we've
been doing many things i mean i keep
mine in a plastic ziploc but i've seen
them in glove compartment boxes i've
seen them like in a pile on the
dashboard these aren't clean medical
instruments the way that people are
imagining that they're helping um the
kids wear the masks for all day long i
think they maybe change them out at
lunchtime but they come to me with food
with bodily fluids um the coffins knees
they don't understand that they're
supposed to change them in between that
like fellow drivers also do the same
thing so it's not just the kids it's
adults um
they're just it's germ factories it's
disgusting and we're not teaching these
kids proper hygiene they just have to
wear a mask that's the only rule so they
can come with ripped masks dirty masks
it doesn't matter as long as they have
something covering their face and this
is this is what the schools are pushing
so um i just wanted to point that out
that if you're gonna send your kid there
has to be a whole system implemented in
this um
it's it's not just one mask for a day
these kids are wearing the same mask
every day it's if if they did a spot
test and just checked
everybody should take your mask off
let's see what's going on on the mask it
would be quite eye opening and i think
that this would stop instantly if we
actually knew what we were breathing in
that's it
thank you very much
alex vanilla
hello again alex manila where i just
want to go on record in support
of hb 1371 couple of comments on this
one
again i just want to
make it clear right there's no solution
to this with two sides opposing each
other right and we can cite studies all
over the place you're not going to
convince the other side you have to do
what's best
for yourself here so the only solution
is to
realize that the power belongs to the
people and for individuals to make
health decisions that are best for
themselves and their families that's the
only solution otherwise we're gonna have
to keep coming here in snowstorms and
you know calling out of work to come
like we're not gonna stop fighting you
guys on this so
pass the bill i i highly recommend that
um
the other thing i heard a question from
representative glitchfield about like
what if we really do need the mask like
what if there's a really bad pandemic we
actually need these things you wouldn't
need legislation at that point right
like if somebody sprayed anthrax all
over the place i i know like all right
i'm in trouble here i need a mask you
know or some a respirator
so you wouldn't really need legislation
people would do it automatically um
and then just one other comment on that
personally i'd rather have a pandemic
rip through society than have tyrants
running around rounding people up for
not wearing masks and not injecting
pharmaceuticals into their bodies that's
insanity that doesn't better society
society works when people have
individual choice it's the only way the
only way this is going to work so i hope
you
consider that and pass this bill thank
you thank you very much
are there questions from the committee
not seeing any thank you
thank you uh stephen petty
thank you to everyone again there were
two topics i wanted to touch on based on
questions that were raised
one
as far as my background goes i'm a
certified industrial hygienist certified
safety professional professional
engineer there's only 200 of us in the
united states
on top of that i was trained in
behavioral psychology i finished first
of my class in behavioral marketing one
of the issues that comes up over and
over again and we need courage from our
legislatures
is
this whole issue of everybody's been
made afraid in the art of persuasion
there's four ways in order of
effectiveness people are persuaded fear
number one
people coiling a ball if they're afraid
and do what they're told
emotional appeal
wear mask to save your fellow citizen
pretty effective
propaganda which means repeated message
ask mass mask
logic least effective mass don't work
appreciate that in context of what's
going on there have been tens of
millions of dollars
to sell a certain message
so we do need some courage the second
point i want to make is in the field of
industrial hygiene
we have what we call hierarchy of
controls i mentioned it briefly but it's
important representative in the corner
said what if we have a student that has
this condition we want to protect them
as opposed to somebody else they need a
mask
that is not the answer under the
hierarchy of controls
masks don't even fit respirators are the
least desirable because our people don't
wear them long term for hours
the most effective control is
engineering controls you have a lot of
state money available
it's not being used to improve the hvac
systems
through improved ventilation fresh air
or better filtration merv 17 or better
or the technologies that actually
destroy the virus those solutions
protect everyone
we don't have to have this mass
respirator argument this is basic
industrial hygiene that goes back to
1950. thank you
thank you very much other questions from
the committee
thank you
over there right there is what
represents
thank you um
the ones that kill everything
are those difficult and expensive to
install in a school
um
the answer is no in fact
in august of 2020 i was approached by a
school district with a high school of
700 autistic children
they could not wear masks
we put in the new calgon eye wave
improved ventilation
i think they had two cases i think were
both brought in that year because the
students wouldn't and couldn't wear
masks
so
at the end of this presentation which
will be made available to everybody i
put in the technologies that and what
their costs are
how how effective they are
for schools you'll need one of two types
of technology one you can put on the
central system if you have
air conditioning that that has duct work
there are some older schools and some
areas where
you don't have doctor work you just have
baseboard or whatever
and there are standalone systems that
i've listed as well and what their costs
are and districts are putting these in
i've consulted for free
with way over a dozen districts if they
if they want to play ball i will talk to
their hvac systems their board whoever
if they give me three minutes i say
don't waste my time if they'll give me
30 minutes i'll donate my time
and and that's happening very frequently
so the solutions are here the costs are
here the effectivenesses are here
um
and i would just say don't get trapped
in this argument about masks for this
group and not this group or respirators
for this group or that group that is the
bottom of the barrel solution and there
are much better solutions they've been
known for 80 years
and just don't get trapped in that
argument
thank you very much
rusan
thank you committee chair thank you
committee members um i actually am
really excited that i was able to go
right after um the last speaker because
i just wanted to bring it up that maybe
it's time to start asking why
why is the school boards doubling down
and and and being bring more and more
school boards are being brought to court
over some of these mandates and some of
the ways they're doing the things
they're doing
why are why now in my school district
is the school board meetings no longer
open to the public
and they're not having them they cancel
them and then they meet and vote behind
because
there's a crisis
so that's a big thing is why are we
still why is this happening
um
it doesn't make sense in a lot of ways
kovid is on the wane
so why are school boards still insisting
why are our school boards and our school
board members and our principals and our
superintendents still saying we can't
trust the parents
we don't want the parents input
we've heard a lot of testimony in this
committee i know that you guys have
heard a lot of testimony in this
committee about how
really kind of ridiculous the school
board seems to be treating parents
maybe it's time to start asking why i
know in my school districts for instance
they would rather put a new they would
rather put
in
um
books that are going to cost all kinds
of litigation
than a system like this person it was
presented that system was presented
they would rather spend the money on
litigating against parents instead of
trying to help our students
develop normal appropriate relationships
i've talked a lot in this committee
about reactive attachment disorder
and um
i encourage you folks to read the
definition i'm not going to read the
definition because i only have three
minutes but the bottom line is is if you
read the definition of retec reactive
attachment disorder and what causes it
that's what we've been doing for our
children for the last two years
why
why are we doing this to our children
why the powers that be said maybe they
were afraid maybe they really thought
that this was the next
the next
polio
maybe they thought it was the next
whatever but why are they still doing it
then
don't you have to say why at some point
when do we say
this doesn't make sense anymore i've
seen a lot of shaming and i've seen a
lot of bullying and i'll tell you part
of my problem is it's much easier to
bully someone
when you don't feel like they're human
anymore
you do this to someone and they're not
human anymore it's easier to bully
someone like this than it is like this
think about that
the other thing is the school boards are
getting a lot i have a school board
candidate right now
that said the reason why he supported
the mass mandate in our school was
because he got more covered money for
supporting
the masks
boom
we're done
thank you thank you do are there any
questions from the committee members
not seeing thank you
this closes our hearing on 1371.
okay
yeah or you can just leave them in there
on the desk and there uh so that you
know anything that was handed out we can
hand out to people when the other
members arrive
yeah that's what we oftentimes do is
just there's a number of things in there
for people who can
okay so we let's go ahead and get this
other one introduced and done
i know you've been looking forward to
this one all day though oh yeah
yeah yeah
and like they stand up
yes sir
huh
uh i don't know i don't know if they've
uh all signed it or not
oh
is
[Music]
you can follow um
uh
there are people here which like to talk
can you please take it to hall we're not
done our business for the day
well i'll tell you you know at first i
thought there was something going on
here and then i said oh yeah they're
down there doing what they're doing i
said jeepers are those jets going over
top
you know what's on my mind right now
it's just
yeah
yeah yeah it sounds like something yes
thank you for coming
it's the blade the blade is on the floor
too bouncing along
is
thank you
okay we're gonna go ahead and start here
folks uh
we have hb 1141 uh on the docket right
now we've heard this once before and we
have an amendment coming back to us
which is
really we needed the second hearing
because it wasn't really germane to the
um
initial introduction bill as introduced
so with that i'd like to welcome
representative cordelli to our committee
meeting
uh and to
introduce would you please uh
hb1141 as you see it
thank you um
and i'll try not to keep you too long
today so we can all get home
hb 1141 was originally submitted as a
placeholder bill
even though ols will tell you that there
is no such thing as a placeholder bill
um
because we wanted to finish up uh the hb
581 study committee that was held this
fall
and based on
testimony to that uh committee
and to other uh discussions with with
parents over the past couple of years
i'm submitting this amendment
and
try to address four main issues
in the amendment
first
related to iep meetings
we had
much
testimony from parents
about what they considered intimidation
um
that entertainment intimidation
taking the form of having
the school district bring their lawyers
to iep meetings
iep meetings the whole process is very
difficult
for parents
especially parents
going through the process the first time
it can be expensive
i i've
heard from advocates who tell the story
of um parents going bankrupt trying to
get services
um
so the first section is on the bottom of
what you have is the first page starting
on line 25
addressing
um
the intimidation factor and really
repeating
in federal law
um
what is is required in an iep meeting
and also
specifying um who are the legal
participants
in a uh
special uh excuse me in an iep meeting
and i have
you know packets for anyone who cares of
all the
federal law involved in this
but um
there is
federal law related to who
is involved in an iep meeting
and
in
no way
would
a school district lawyer
be an eligible participant in an iep
meeting
so i want to get that into statute
so that parents
have
hopefully along the way the knowledge
that
that is not
proper and they can object to that
participant being in the meeting
second coming down on page two section 4
rule making
we had testimony about
how wonderful it is that
new hampshire goes
beyond state law
and federal law
in rules related to special education
i have a problem
with that
i have a problem with any
executive
branch
agency
going beyond what is in state law or
federal law
rules should be based on
law
in many cases here
and
i can give you that was handed out at
the 581 subcommittee a chart that shows
where
new hampshire rules go beyond
state law or federal law
so
i'm putting in here that
it has to be consistent with law any
rule making
thirdly
um
mediation starts right below that in
section five
um
and we heard from many parents
about
being forced to find
forced to sign
non-disclosure agreements
i
and that is what you see following there
but
mediation
is supposed to be a confidential process
and that that's in federal law and
i recognize that
but also in federal law
is the fact that it is illegal
to
force a parent going into mediation
to sign a non-disclosure or a
confidentiality agreement
so i want to get that
um on the record in law as well
and fourth
um is covered over on starting on page
three
in section six
and that is access to student
information
um we've heard from multiple parents
about
not being able to get
records
not
finding all the proper documentation in
those
records from the
school board and the school district
and
federal law also provides if they see
something that has been put into the
record they have the abi the right to
object and um
object to that and uh uh go through a
process to
possibly have any misinformation as they
see it corrected so i wanted to get
that into law as well
so i think that all of this is um
consistent with federal law and refers
in in most cases to the chapter um in
ida that applies
um and so that is the um
intent of this
amending language
to address those four areas that we
heard
often from parents
thank you
thank you very much are there questions
representative hobson and then
representative moffat
thank you mr chair uh thank you for your
testimony today representative cordelli
um i i may have other questions i'm
still processing but my first question
is
i guess this is page 3
line 16 i think you said
that
information could be added to a
student's folder that the parent might
not want
in the folder and i'm just wondering
what might be an example of that because
i can't think of
something that fits like
it
i cannot remember testimony specific to
that from parents but there were
certainly
complaints
about
things that they objected to
being in there
things that they
felt were missing
information that was brought
to iep meetings
that they felt was
inaccurate or
not complete
in more cases uh
than not it was more on the uh
incomplete information um they felt not
being presented as part of the the
record for their child
so um
they should have the right to
review all those records and make sure
that the record um is complete and
accurate
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
my question so i'm just looking at this
amendment for the first time and on it
says page three at the top uh the new
language on if you go down to sub
paragraphs j and k
juliet and kilo
so lines 13 through
18.
so if you look at line 13 this is
discussions that occur during the
mediation process shall be confidential
and then if you go to line 16 the next
subparagraph
parties to the mediation
process shall not be required to sign a
confidentiality pledge
so
help me out a little bit here
it seems to me that those two
statements are in opposition to each
other or am i not i might just i
i understand your your question
and um
per law
the mediation process is confidential
but at the same time going into
mediation
you cannot be required to sign a
non-disclosure agreement
and that also is in federal law
as and as it says there or as a
precondition
to going into mediation
okay
thank you
representative luno
thank you very much mr chair um i've got
a uh just a couple i think just a couple
of questions um right now but i think i
i know i'm gonna have more when we come
to the exact session sure that's
and i'd be glad to give you any of this
information from the idea well that
would be really helpful thank you very
much sure
um so um so first question is um in
section two of line i'm sorry page one
line 18
where you use the term full participants
and i was wondering how that is
different than than
sort of regular participants
and if there and are our full
participants somehow implying that
other participants are either partial or
have less um
it was
not my intention um to indicate that
they are any different than others
participation uh participants i'm sorry
um uh just that uh and again if we look
at law there are requirements um
uh
that parents do not have to be involved
in an iep meeting but there is a process
that has to be
gone through to make sure that they have
been given the opportunity and
documented the opportunity
to attend that meeting so i just wanted
to make sure that
parent participation and even the child
when
possible participation
is provided for okay so it doesn't mean
that an iep meeting cannot go forward if
a parent has decided not to participate
that is correct yes okay thank you for
that and then um
another question
for this afternoon
under current law
what cost obligations does a residential
or does the district of re
district of residence
have for students with ieps
who are attending schools outside the
district
um
it depends on what kind of school
if if they're attending a charter school
within the district then it's
incumbent upon the resident district to
provide um for the services
let me rephrase the question i i i um
what i meant is attending a school
that's not part of that school district
may it may be within the district they
live but um like a private school a
private school or a charter school or
something like that
with a private school um if the parent
places their child in a private school
there's a whole process defined in id
idea it's um called parental placement
and there is a formula worked out from
the title one for funds
total number of kids in that district
with ieps um the funds available from
title one and then what percentage of
those funds would follow that child
to the private school
for uh
services provided under uh
not an iep but an interval service plan
that is provided at that school okay so
so
i'm just trying to get to the
distinction between a fape and an iep
and
special education services
and um and in section seven page four
line four you talk about the district of
residence having to
district
residents shall fund
a free and appropriate public education
for children with disabilities
um and it keeps going in the least
restricted environment and finishing out
the you know
in which the students iep can be
implemented but the the cost portion of
that is lines four and five there is a
shall fund a free and appropriate
education for children with disabilities
um
and this is obviously pertaining to
students who are attending
a uh charter school
right or their resident school district
right yeah well well there's there's two
different things here because
um if you're if if you're a child with
an iep and you're going you're attending
your resident school district
that school districts
they're in charge of all the costs the
same way they're in charge of all the
costs for a student that doesn't have an
iep right but for charter it's very
different they're under current law i do
not believe they have the full
the obligation for the full cost of
educating
a student with or without an iep but
they do have an obligation for special
education costs
and that's different than a faith isn't
that right
with the charter school
the resident district
is still responsible for the services
for that child there's an iep we had
legislation this year about
communication between the charter school
and the
resident district about that and
notification of iep meetings etc but um
uh yeah i believe that the resident
district is still responsible for the
free
appropriate education and then um just
has to work out with the charter school
um where those services are performed
basically but is isn't a free and
appropriate educate the balloon of a
free and appropriate education larger
than the then what's inside of it that
is specifically
special education services
um
in this case we're talking
i'm talking about a
special child with a disability is
eligible for
um free and appropriate education they
they are under under idea eligible for
free and appropriate education
um
i believe the new hampshire law says the
district of residence
is not
a childish for an iep student
attending a charter school is
responsible for special education costs
not the full cost of a fake isn't that
oh i i think i know what you what you
i'm just trying
the resident district is responsible for
the uh
the services specialized services for
that child right um the rest of the
education um
is on the charter right based on the
tuition uh that they are getting from
the state for that child right so is
this changing that
um it's it's not intended to could you
repeat where where
on on page four lines four and five
um yeah that that was not intended to um
change anything related to a charter
school okay so that so so really that's
to the resident district shall fund the
special education services
for children with disabilities in at
least in the least restrictive
environment
your emphasis there was really the least
respected environment right student
right
okay yes okay
are there further questions you thank
you very much
thank you representative representative
kerdelli thank you for explaining this
um an awful lot of what you have in here
is repeating what's already in federal
law and i'm trying to understand why
you're doing that
um
thank you i
if you look at ida it's um
quite voluminous
as well as all the parent handbooks and
state law and rules and so forth
um
a lot of this
is coming from parents and it
in many cases it's not happening
in
accordance with law
i felt it important to
put this
into state law just so that um
it's there for anyone to refer to
um
i'm just trying to
address
in multiple
ways
to allow parents to get the services
that they're entitled to
and i thought that by
putting it into state law was necessary
but also providing the reference to
federal law if the parents so choose to
to look at the federal law
um
i i felt it important to put it into rsa
our rsas because a lot of this wasn't
addressed specifically in our rsas
so if you do not use the exact same
language as a federal law
it would suggest to me that you may be
perhaps creating a confusing situation
for those parents
because they're not lawyers they're not
going to know how to read it and they
probably don't know the federal law
trumps state law in every one of these
cases and i'm concerned that
and i don't know without going back and
looking at federal law where you are
using the exact same language as federal
law and where you sort of tried to
rewrite it into
what you think federal law is saying and
i'm wondering if you can help me
understand
what's happening here like where are you
capping state law and where are you sort
of rewriting i mean capping federal law
where are you kind of rewriting i i i
thank you for the question i'm not
trying to
um
add anything
um specifically um
so
i think in most cases what you see in
bold is coming
pretty much directly from
the state law excuse me the federal law
the id idea i'm not trying to um
go beyond that
um
in some cases maybe um
the language uh might um
be a little more uh
non-legal
um there's in federal law but um you
know i'll give you the the sections that
i'm referring to and um
but i i wasn't trying to go beyond
what's there creating anything new
specifically
but just putting into our law you know
what the options are for parents in
regard to ieps
mediation and access to information
so
i
haven't been at one point the parent of
a special ed child i know that you get
the booklet that's got all that stuff in
it based on federal law
um so
is that already in the booklet
um
yes
there are several booklets
um that run um you know between 60 and
200 pages if you depending on which
booklet you're looking at and my looking
at some of the booklets um is very
confusing to me and i think we've talked
about um in the department has
started to look at
rewriting some of those because
in some cases it seems to contradict one
another between the booklets so i think
that
clarification by the department in these
handbooks is also necessary and i think
that they recognize that as well
so
so i have a question and this is not
meant to be nest your condescending and
i don't want it to come across that way
in any way so you talk about how big the
federal law is we have a big book here
too yes we know parents are not
necessarily looking at the underlying
statutes they're looking at those
booklets so my honest question is what
does putting it in
adding it to that booklet why is it any
different than what's sitting in the
thank you thank you
yeah um
i i think it's also um important not
just for parents but for school
districts
uh to see that because um you know i i
don't know if they're gonna go you know
searching through all this either um but
a lot of these things
are happening and they shouldn't be
happening
and i think it's important to get it
into our statutes
so that districts
know what the parameters are as well
but isn't the remedy not
putting it more in statutes i mean like
many people here we have way too i think
we have way too much instead both the
federal especially the federal level but
the state level too we have way too much
too many words is what i'm trying to say
trying to accomplish what we do
and and
you know
i spent five years with the us
department of education office for civil
rights enforcing special ed laws among
other things
and
it what was in the books whether it was
in the books or in the books once or
twice it didn't matter what mattered was
whether a school dish chose to do it and
the school districts were all aware of
it they were making conscious decisions
not to follow the law
and i'm still
at a loss and again just this is just me
i'm still in a losses to understand why
putting federal law in our state law is
going to change anything when it's
already the law in the books school
districts are going to follow it or
they're not going to follow it and and i
don't understand what making the book
fatter is really going to do
it is my hope that
it will maybe help in a small way so
that some of these things that
um are supposed to be followed according
to federal law will be followed um
i think there will be multiple attempts
um
some in the senate i know
is this
there was other legislation we've passed
in
relation to special education
but i think
special education
and
services
to parents are an important topic and
need to be addressed and this is just a
another way i wanted to uh to address it
um
you know having you know parents come in
here like we saw with the 581 commission
you know crying
parents going bankrupt
we need to do things to address special
education
let me try this
i would just suggest that maybe what we
need to be looking at is our enforcement
mechanism rather than just getting one
of the thick books
that is well i wouldn't disagree
on on the enforcement part
i have a question for you representative
cordelli
um
i'm not trying to be picky but i've gone
to a situation that has been a difficult
one
when i was sitting in iep meetings every
week with parents
parents
verse parent
singular or plural
is used at varying places within the
legislation that you have here on line
30 on page two it's parent with an
apostrophe s so it's the parent that one
parent is not a plural
is in possession there of that right to
the hearing up top we're talking on
lines 10 the parents of the child may
object to participation i've been in
situations
where there are two parents
not living together
and
fighting with each other and one wants
and one doesn't want
and so
um
i the parents of the child may object to
the participation of an individual in
the iep team meeting
well you know you may not have both
parents one might be in afghanistan well
no longer afghanistan but hopefully but
somewhere else in the military and the
one that's at home
is going to be making that decision or
the one that's now living down in texas
may not like this going on my child's
not special service doesn't need that
and so how do we account for in the and
i know in in federal law when i remember
reading it when you're setting up the
meetings the parent doesn't have to but
they have to have the opportunity to
participate
correct um and it talks about the parent
uh so
it would be wise that we try to clean
this up a little bit in terms of where
we're are we talking about the parent or
parents you have to have permission of
both of them to do something
um
i'm just i don't think i just don't have
to have that
right i i'm just looking at uh section
300.321
um of federal law the iep team and um a1
says the parents of a child
so you know
you know i i reckon is your point but um
you know yeah i i see it too and i'm
looking at 322 and it says parent
participation right but then you get
down and you start reading it and they
bounce around between the plural too yes
uh
so i i understand that but this has been
very you know i've had a lot of conflict
with it
um when i you know one wants to bring an
attorney in to do something the other
one says i don't want anything to do
with that
um so
something to consider
representative
that that's not a term in new hampshire
anymore the
that's not a term in new hampshire
anymore there's no such thing in new
hampshire as a custodial parent
really
well you can appearance or a guardian
well you know okay i
i have no more questions uh uh uh
representative cordelia at this time um
are there
others because we have bonnie that wants
to step up to the plate i'm sure i don't
want any pink card yep there's one
okay thank you
no he he testified illegally
could we strike everything he said then
well you can give it a shot bonnie
welcome
hi
i'm bonnie dunham and i am here as a
parent of a young man who benefited from
special education under our current
special education law and rules
and so i value them highly
i have to say
and i understand things happen but i am
so disappointed that with almost no
notice we are talking about making
significant changes in our state special
education rights and protections the
very rights and protections that parents
and children with disabilities have come
to rely upon for their children's
well-being
and
i've talked to several parents in the
past few days none of them knew this was
happening
it's not in the calendar it just says an
amendment which you couldn't get your
hands on until halfway through tuesday
and you had to go to the sergeant of
arms office and then later it was
available online
there were a lot of people here for that
mask mandate because they had months to
know about it to prepare for it this is
just not fair to families to parents and
i know that's not something
representative cordelia intends to to be
as unfair to parents
the new hampshire special education laws
have historically been reviewed and
revised through very thoughtful
processes that encourage stakeholder
involvement the last time there were
significant changes made to rsa 186c a
work group made up of about one-third
people representing parents a third
representing school districts and the
third legislators held a series of
meetings and public input sessions
simultaneously our state state special
education rules were being reviewed and
revised hundreds of people participated
in those processes directly
and more than 700 signed a petition
supporting the language that we have now
if everything in rsa 186c
was should be
the um should be the absolute standard
and that
we shouldn't have anything in the rules
that go beyond that then perhaps we
should go through the new hampshire
standards and pick out everything that's
important to families and put it in rsa
186c then it would be longer
but that would no longer be an issue
rsa 186e doesn't have detail it says
children are evaluated and determined
eligible by the iep by the school
district it doesn't say who evaluates
them how long it can take what the
requirements are
what what's prohibited that detail is in
the new hampshire standards and and
that's how it's always been and if we're
going to change it it should be done
extremely thoughtfully
this amendment would lower many of the
important special education rights and
protections to the bare minimum required
by idea idea is intended to be a floor
not a ceiling
and states are allowed to go beyond that
and new hampshire does new hampshire
complies with idea as we must but we
also reflect new hampshire's unique
character history and values by
including extra procedures that support
parent involvement which research has
shown is the number one factor in in
ensuring student success in school
they provide clarity accountability
transparency they use sound business
practices and include requirements to
better prepare students for life after
high school
specifically this amendment deletes the
requirement in 186c to include
short-term objectives or benchmarks in
each child's iep unless the parent
agrees they are not necessary for one or
more of the child's annual goals
during the last major revision of new
hampshire's special ed laws and rules
because they happen simultaneously 80
more than 89 percent of people who
reference short-term objectives in their
oral testimony supported our current
language i was the notetaker for that
for that work group and i went to every
single hearing in every single public
meeting and i took
voluminous notes and so i was able to
calculate that
short term objectives allow parents and
educators to understand how a child with
a disability will achieve their annual
goals they provide a tool for parents to
monitor and support their children's
short-term success require them to write
those steps down so that parents also
know them
several parents who testified said that
short-term objectives were the single
most important component of the iep in
enabling them to meaningful meaningfully
participate in their children's
education
also because ida only requires those
short-term objectives or benchmarks for
children who take alternate assessments
aligned to alternate achievement
standards no preschooler no child who
doesn't take a statewide assessment
including those whose parents opt them
out would ever have short-term
objectives in their iep i don't know
that that's what you mean to do or that
people think that's the best idea
and then
some additional requirements that we
have for new hampshire clear timelines
we don't believe in enough reasonable we
want to know a number of days so there's
no disagreement everybody has a shared
understanding
of what's intended beginning transition
planning by age 14 is we go beyond the
federal law and our and more of our kids
who finish school are employed or in
post-secondary education after they
finish a year after high school than in
almost any other state
section 3 of the amendment says that iep
team meetings should be scheduled at a
mutually agreed upon time and place idea
requires that they must be scheduled at
a mutually agree upon time and place
section 504 about
adds a piece that talks about
confidentiality and and all of that and
much of that is already in 186 c23 but
not not ndas that's that is not in there
um and so it would make sense to add
something about that um but
the
section about parent rights access
rights there's a there's an error that
probably unintentionally reduces parents
rights because most of that's in ferpa
but new hampshire carefully considered
and decided that we wanted to go beyond
the minimum requirement in ferpa we
wanted to go beyond that floor
and
while that amendment requires districts
to comply with the parents request to
inspect and review records in no case
less than 45 days after the request is
made
rsa 189.66 sets a much shorter 14-day
timeline for families in new hampshire
to be provided with that access to their
child's school records
i think the amendment's flawed it
lessens parents rights it lessens
opportunities for parents to be involved
in the special ed process and in fact in
their child's education
i'm not saying everything is perfect it
is not but this is not the answer such
major changes in new hampshire special
education law should not be rushed we
have a long history of respecting and
involving parents including when rsa
186c has been revised please don't let
this amendment end that practice please
either oppose it or refer
for further study and if i if you don't
mind if i answer any questions that you
had about what happens when parents
don't agree
really interestingly the office of
special education programs issues
letters when questions come up like that
because idea allows a parent to revoke
consent for special education and then
the question is what if one parent wants
to revoke and the other doesn't and the
answer is the parent has a right one
parent has a right to revoke it the
other parent has the right to re-refer
their child for special education and
then the first parent can revoke it and
so the federal law was unwilling to
deprive either parent of the rights that
they had and in doing so they kind of
created a catch-22 that um that
that they recognize osep recognized
would torment school districts
luckily it doesn't happen that often but
when it does there is no clear answer
and um it'd be great if there's like
politicians wrote it yeah oh they yes
they did congress wrote it but with a
lot of input from people so that and
they i think they didn't know there was
going to be a catch-22 until it was
pointed out in that letter that they got
that
representative
i was just going to say that issue
coming up across the hall and child and
family over and over again
exactly what you're describing that ping
pong back and forth and it was usually
resolved in the courts in the cases of
who had parental authority
which is to go with what representatives
florida's talking about
not law not called custody anymore it's
it's called co-parenting and that's why
you can't use the word custody in new
hampshire
so
but just i'm going to say i've heard
that issue just across the hall in a
different form
are there
well there's questions reps and hobson
thank you mr chair
and i will not profess to know
everything there is to know about
special education i did not have a
special education student however
um i was looking at
the bill uh on the very first page the
part in bold in
number 17 through 20. it indicates uh
that the parent of a child shall be full
participants on the individual
individualized education program
is that um does that pose a problem
based on the
original language the word full
participants does not pose a problem in
fact may you want to say full and equal
which you technically already are but it
might emphasize it more but on the iep
team pursuant to 34 cfr sections 300 321
and 322 that's a problem because new
hampshire has additional members of the
iep team that we've determined are
important new hampshire has
extra criteria to encourage and
facilitate parent involvement in the
process um and so
i'm concerned that some of that language
would take away those protections that
were done so thoughtfully
many with the consent with the agreement
of variety of a variety of stakeholders
in new hampshire we require parents to
be given copies of evaluation results
five days before meetings so they can
read them and be prepared not walk in
and be blindsided the federal law has
not decided yet to be as progressive as
new hampshire wish they did but they had
not and so we do what's right in new
hampshire just like we closed the state
institution for people with disabilities
and we don't allow people to pay below
minimum wage to people with disabilities
because it's not right federal law says
it's okay federal law says you can use
electric shocks on children with
disabilities new hampshire says you
cannot do we want to revert to what the
federal law allows i think
not follow up
i just wanted to ask um
do you think it's necessary to have a
lawyer at an iep meeting
that was a bit shocking to me
yes um
i think most often it is not um
sometimes parents bring one sometimes
schools bring one sometimes they bring
non-attorney um
non-attorney members or representatives
from law firms um and so that can be a
problem idea allows that a parent or a
school district an lea can can invite
others who have special knowledge or
expertise about the child um it's
somewhat unfortunate though that the one
doing the inviting gets to be the one
who decides um
and and so that can lead to some
conflict but it but it's allowed if but
they have to say that they have special
knowledge or expertise in the analysis
of comments and discussion um add on to
the federal regulations that question
came up and um and the u.s department of
education in their response
discourages people from bringing
unnecessary people including attorneys
to meetings they don't prohibit it
because the way the law is written they
technically couldn't but they definitely
do discourage it
and so maybe we could ask the department
to issue a memo
mimicking that language
discouraging in
representatives
would you be willing or have you already
and i haven't seen it
um
point out the exact areas like you did
on the one full participants the part
that came after that the discrepancies
that you see
just as a list so that we can go over
them and look at them would you be
willing to do that sure i have i mean i
don't have it with me right well i have
kind of it with me right this second but
i'm not in not in the level of detail of
the accurate descriptions that you that
you deserve i could definitely pull that
together for you though
and i because i was the note taker for
the committee that senate previous
senator stiles was running to look at
our state laws i have lots of
background about the discussions and how
some of these decisions were made
and
i also i encourage you to read the
comments the analysis of comments and
discussion and idea because it answers
some questions it's it's long but it's
fascinating reading truly
thank you
we also have available to us
to get a side by side of this amendment
first
current law in this state
and that can be done and that what's
that's what jen does and jen's
background over in hawaii was attorney
slash
special education
if that's something you could possibly
do or not
but it's something i see you frequently
doing upstairs is you know current law
to whatever we're talking about
mr chairman can i ask that if jen does
that we have she included that federal
law as well state law because i was
actually going to ask representative
cordelli to because he said he was
following federal law to tell me where
he digresses from federal law so i just
somebody i don't care who it is but
somebody should say here's what's in the
bill here's state law here's federal law
so we can see the three different
standards and understand the effect of
what we're doing and where it digresses
from federal law whether we are
expanding or minimizing well trying to
minimize rights because you can't
minimize under federal law but if our
language is going to be less than
federal law we should know that we're
putting confusing language in there so i
i'm thinking that it'd be helpful if she
looks at both
where we do more than federal law
more frequently i would think and that
for some of the same reasons that just
been explained to us but there you you
could do that with you know this this
and this if you got a wide enough piece
of paper
well we just heard testimony about how
the cfrs that we
this would actually limit what's under
current law and even in some cases limit
federal law and i just want to be sure
that's clear so i think that can be
added in right
in
new hampshire we have
the guide to the new hampshire standards
i typed it
where the regulations that we have the
new hampshire standards in many places
like this does refers to the federal law
they just cite federal law
and below each place that does that i
included a box with the exact text from
the federal law
that
if changes are made where we do just
refer to the federal law in some places
and hopefully add plus
because they that reflect new
hampshire's values
having a version of it that had
something like that a hundred percent of
the people who testified um the last
time the uh line rules were revised
found that extra piece that we had
always done to be helpful
if you have that information can you
share it with jennifer
yes so whatever's not in the box by the
way would be
state it saves some time and we're under
this the timeline here of we exact these
bills on the set on the 7th or the 8th
so we have a week
so you could but you could make this go
to interim study and then you wouldn't
have just a week would you but i think
we'd like to see it when you know during
that exact session oh good god okay yeah
yeah i know
yes
it's very pretty isn't it yes
okay
well
are you supposed to be commenting when
you present
we don't want to get there you could
but
given the time we have it's not not a
half-bad idea
um
yeah lunch has passed um
getting ready for
supper
so is are there any other questions from
the committee for bonnie right now we
could we can talk to bonnie after we
close this thing down a little bit if
there's something that further
communicate with jen or work with them
no further questions good uh we've been
done this
this hearing today and done our work for
today jenna is that going to be possible
to get something back by that exact
session
yeah bonnie was very uh you know
involved when we've done a lot of this
in the past so she's a resource which
you should tag into
if i'm
lobbying so to speak i'm speaking i'm
always here as a private
you